Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio Nummer 279 nach, ich wollte gerade sagen nach
langer Zeit, aber das stimmt ja gar nicht, weil es gab ja gerade eine Folge, auch wenn
das was ganz anderes war, aber eben jetzt mal wieder ein Chaos Radio, was auch immer das bedeutet.
Das wird sich vielleicht in der Zukunft auch ändern. Anyways, heute sprechen wir wieder, wie wir das im Chaos Radio so machen, über ein Thema.
Das irgendwie mit unserer digitalen Welt zu tun hat, wo irgendwie Dinge kaputt sind oder
kaputt sein könnten oder dazu gebracht werden, dass man sie vielleicht kaputt machen kann
und wie sich das mit uns, der Gesellschaft und der IT-Technologie alles sozusagen so
zusammenschweißt oder auseinanderfällt, das werden wir alles sehen. Und es geht heute
um etwas, was immer mal wieder so Thema ist, aber auf einer anderen Ebene, wie wir das
sonst hier besprechen. Es geht um einerseits irgendwas mit Gesundheit, irgendwas mit digital
und dann, das ist der große Unterschied, heute im Hauptthema oder im Hauptfokus muss
muss man sagen, Europa. Wie das alles zusammenhängt, verrät uns jetzt unter anderem Bianca Kastl,
deren Hauptberuf, habe ich mir sagen lassen, es ist Faxe aus dem Gesundheitswesen zu vertreiben.
Oder man kann es, glaube ich, auch anders formulieren. Sie ist Vorsitzende des Innovationsverbundes
öffentliche Gesundheit. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen. Hallo.
Kurze Frage, wie vertreibt man dann Faxe aus seinem Gesundheitssystem?
Naja, man macht sinnvollen digitalen Kram.
Achso, und das geht? Ja, dazu kommen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich dann gleich auch.
Außerdem die beiden CCC-Sprecherinnen, Konz und Khaleesi, hallo und herzlich Willkommen.
Hallo. Hi. Die man auch noch in ganz vielen anderen Kontexten vorstellen könnte, aber dann wäre wahrscheinlich
die Sendung auch vorbei, deswegen belassen wir es jetzt einfach dafür.
Konz guckt ganz, Konz was habe ich vergessen zu sagen? Nein, du hast nichts vergessen.
Wir haben schließlich hier thematisch zu besprechen, wir müssen uns ja nicht gegenseitig.
CCC-Sprecherinnen umfasst doch alles.
Das ist Sache und Fachkunde in digitalen Themen, Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, Lobbyismus, da ist
doch einfach alles drin. Mehr muss man doch eigentlich gar nicht, oder?
Ja, wie würde ich dir widersprechen? Also du kannst es sehr gut, aber das ist vielleicht ein…
Ja, können wir zum Thema kommen?
Jetzt, schnell! Es ist auch sehr lustig, weil Konz im Vorgespräch, ja es gibt Chaosradios mit Vorgesprächen
gesagt hat, vielleicht sollten wir offenlegen, dass wir das nicht zum ersten Mal zusammen machen.
Ich sage, das wird schon gehen, aber das wird eine spannende Situation.
Jetzt können wir das aber offenlegen. Das hast du noch nicht gesprochen, jetzt müssen wir das auch offenlegen.
Aber jetzt weiß man auch schon wieder alles, was man dazu wissen muss, oder?
Ja, das stimmt.
Es ist also, vor vielen Jahren, liebe KinderInnen, war es einmal ein Chaos-Radio. In dem auch schon.
Anyways. Es soll heute um Gesundheitsdaten gehen. Wir haben vergessen, den Moderator vorzustellen.
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Wir haben einen Moderator, er heißt Markus Richter und wir schätzen ihn seit Jahren
hier und heute besonders. Das sagt Konst nur, damit mir jetzt der Schweiß, der Lobschweiß ausbricht und ich nicht mehr
weiß, was ich sagen soll. Zum Thema aber, Leute, Gesundheitsdaten.
Wenn man Gesundheitsdaten und Digitales hört.
Dann könnte man als jemand, der nicht tief in diesem Thema drinsteckt und das sozusagen ganz verfolgt oder auch Arbeit dazu macht, könnte man zwei Dinge davon halten.
Einerseits Gesundheits-Apps. Da reden wir heute vielleicht am Rande drüber, da geht es aber nicht drum.
Aber da gibt es die quasi letzte reguläre Chaos-Radio-Folge von vor 3000 Jahren ungefähr.
Aber das war die letzte Folge. Oh ein Jahr, so alt ist die nicht. Ne, die ist doch wirklich nachher 10 Jahre.
Die ist ziemlich genau ein Jahr alt.
Die kann man echt hören. Und ihr meint, man kann die auch noch hören, sozusagen, lässt mittlerweile nichts anderes angeboren.
Also man kann immer gut Folgen der Zervorschis hören, wenn sie wieder irgendwas kaputt gemacht haben.
A. Okay, gut. Und das andere, was man vielleicht denken könnte, ist, es geht irgendwie um die elektronische Patientenakte,
deren Einführung in Deutschland jetzt seit Jahren passiert, habe ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl.
Es ist es aber beide nicht. Und deswegen wäre meine erste Frage an euch heute so ein bisschen, worüber genau reden wir eigentlich?
Es hat vier Buchstaben, es heißt E-D-H-S. E-H-D-S. Es ist fantastisch, E-H-D-S.
Worüber reden wir heute und warum hat es nichts mit den aktuellen Dingen zu tun, die
in Deutschland gerade passieren?
Ich glaube wir reden vor allen Dingen über so einen Trend, weswegen wir uns zwei verschiedene
Beispiele genommen haben. Also die europäische Seite, die wir noch besprechen wollen, aber auch die deutsche Seite.
Denn wir haben in Deutschland ein Gesetz, das die Gesundheitsdaten zentralisiert.
Es ist auch längst in Kraft getreten, es wird auch praktisch-technisch umgesetzt, ist aber wenigen Menschen überhaupt bekannt.
Es ist das digitale Versorgungsgesetz und das damit zusammenhängende Forschungsdatenzentrum.
A. Warte, da will ich gleich einfach, es gibt ja diese elektronische Patientennacht, wo die Idee dahinter ist,
unsere Krankenkassenkarte ist quasi auch ein Speicherding oder der Zugriff auf ein Speicherding, wo unsere Gesundheitsdaten drin sind.
Und geht es jetzt darum, die Daten, die darin sind, zu zentralisieren, oder geht es darum,
was irgendwo Gesundheitsdaten sind, zu zentralisieren.
Naja, wir können da glaube ich nochmal drauf kommen, was die Idee dahinter ist. Die ist ja ein bisschen unterschiedlich für die europäische Ebene und für die deutsche.
Aber erst könntest du meine Frage beantworten.
Ja, würde ich gerne tun. In Deutschland ist es so, dass es hinter dem Rücken der Patienten passiert, während ja diese Patientenakte direkt mit den Patienten zu tun hat und mit den Arztgängen oder so.
Und hier ist es so, dass die Krankenkassen die Daten übermitteln, nur die gesetzlichen allerdings, also von mehr als 70 Millionen Menschen.
So um die 73 Millionen Menschen, die gesetzlich krankenfasiert sind,
landen diese Daten in einem Prozess hinter den Rücken der Patienten in einem zentralisierten Forschungsdatenzentrum.
Also das ist jetzt ganz unabhängig davon, was Lauterbach jetzt kürzlich für die Patientenakte vorgeschlagen hat
und was ja auch schon ein ewig langer Prozess ist bei der Digitalisierung.
Das ist ein Teilbereich der Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen, aber einer, wo letztlich die Leute aktiv nichts damit zu tun haben,
Denn sie haben keinerlei Rechte in dem Sinne von sie könnten widersprechen oder sie werden
irgendwie gefragt oder so.
Aber also heißt platt formuliert ist es so, wir reden über Gesundheitsdaten, die sowieso
anfallen, die sowieso bei den gesetzlichen Krankenkassen liegen und jetzt geht...
Herr Lauterbach oder die europäische Politik, werden wir gleich noch erfahren werden wahrscheinlich,
hin und sagt so, das möchten wir gerne alles an einem Ort speichern.
Genau, aber hier ist es ein bisschen älter. Ich habe ja schon gesagt, das Gesetz ist in Kraft.
Das wird schon praktisch getan. Also das verdanken wir Jens Spahn von der CDU.
Danke, danke Jens. Nee, CDU, also der berühmte Kompetenzminister.
Und wir haben ja sozusagen jetzt hier schon mit den Auswirkungen zu kämpfen,
während das europäische Projekt, auf das wir ja noch kommen wollen,
in der Mache ist und auch gerade im politischen Streit.
Also da können wir ja nochmal drauf kommen, an welcher Stelle in Europa in diesem Politikprozess gerade ist.
Aber der Trend ist derselbe. Nämlich Daten zusammenzuholen zentral und aus so ein bisschen den Forderungen, vor allen Dingen aus dem Bereich der medizinischen Forschung, aber auch der Gesundheitsberichterstattung,
diesen Forderungen nachzukommen, dass die alle Zukunft zu diesen Daten wollen. Das ist ein Zeitgeistphänomen, was sicherlich auch mit der Pandemie zusammenhängt.
Ja, das wollen wir noch genau auseinandernehmen, aber vielleicht können wir gleich die europäische Ebene da dran hängen. Also in Deutschland ist es so, es gibt die Daten, es gibt sie bei den Kassen und es gibt schon ein Gesetz, was sagt, diese Daten, die wollen wir alle irgendwie sammeln. Wie genau, können wir gleich noch klären.
Was ist denn auf der europäischen Ebene gedacht? Ist es da, liebe Länder, macht das alle so, wie Deutschland das macht? Oder ist es sozusagen, wir wollen für die EU eine zentrale Datensammlung? Oder was wird da geplant?
Also im Prinzip ist der europäische Gesundheitsdatenraum der Versuch, auf europäischer Ebene einen gemeinsamen Datenraum zu schaffen. Datenraum klingt mir so spannend.
Das klingt total science fiction-hessig.
Eigentlich will man in ganz Europa die Möglichkeit haben, einerseits für die sogenannte Primärnutzung, das heißt einerseits, du möchtest irgendwie ein elektronisches Rezept irgendwie in Spanien ausgehändigt bekommen und möchtest es in Deutschland einlösen.
Das ist die eine Ebene, aber es gibt halt auch die Sekundärnutzung, also das Thema, das du sagen könntest,
alle europäischen Forschungsanliegen sollen jetzt auch Zugriff haben auf alle europäischen Daten.
Die dann durch Interoperabilität und Standards auch die Möglichkeit bieten zu sagen,
okay, ich möchte jetzt irgendwie alle zum Thema von irgendwelchen seltenen Krankheiten in ganz Europa forschen,
nicht nur in zum Beispiel Deutschland, weil man kann ja ganz Europa als einen Wirtschaftsdaten Single Digital Market sehen,
der eben so groß ist, dass er lukrativ genug ist für europäische Unternehmen gegen amerikanische Datenräume und sonstige Dinge, auch groß genug und interessant zu sein.
Also es gibt zwei Nutzungsszenarien oder vielleicht kann man es richtig gucken sozusagen. Was ist denn das Narrativ? Das klingt so ein bisschen Fortschritt durch Digitalisierung. Einerseits für die Partei.
Es ist nicht Fortschritt durch Digitalisierung, sondern das Lieblingsnarrativ ist ja Heilung durch Digitalisierung.
Ah, okay. Da sind schon mehrere Ebenen. Wir bleiben gesund und werden schneller gesund, wenn wir krank sind, weil unsere Daten digital
gespeichert werden. Genau. jetzt mal aus.
Ich weiß nicht, VerbraucherInnenperspektive, aber sozusagen aus der Perspektive
des einzelnen Menschen, der vielleicht krank wird und so weiter und so fort,
klingt das ja erstmal ganz plausibel.
Nämlich das eine Ding ist eben sozusagen, Dinge, die ich machen muss, werden einfacher.
Also halt Rezepte einlösen, gerade das Beispiel, oder vielleicht auch Arztbesuche international.
Ich erinnere mich sehr gerne, wie ich mal in Spanien beim Zahnarzt war und dann musste ich hier wieder erklären und so weiter und so fort.
Also das klingt erstmal ganz gut und auch dieses andere, also es gibt medizinische Daten und aus den medizinischen Daten
Da kann man vielleicht auch wieder was forschen. Das klingt erstmal gut. Und ich bin mir sicher, wir kommen im Verlauf der nächsten Stunde noch dazu, warum Dinge kaputt sind und so weiter und so fort.
Aber sind das erstmal als Ziele, wo ihr sagt, okay, das kann man schon verfolgen wollen oder ist das schon eine Stelle, wo ihr sagt, nein?
Ich glaube, einen Aspekt haben wir gerade noch. Also Bianca hat ja gerade gesagt, irgendwie Wirtschaftsraum, Datenraum. Wir kommen gegen die amerikanischen Wirtschaftsräume ein.
Ein Aspekt dieser Zentralisierung ist natürlich auch, dass da auch Wirtschaftsinteressen dahinter stecken.
Also wir haben ja nicht nur, keine Ahnung, die Forschungsinstitute, die Interesse daran haben, dass es irgendwelche Schnittstellen gibt,
an denen sie Daten bekommen können, um ihre Forschung voranzutreiben, sondern die ersten, die natürlich dann auch auf der Matte stehen,
sind natürlich irgendwie Google, Amazon, alle großen Tech-Unternehmen,
die das auch nutzen wollen, um ihre Applikationen entsprechend zu trainieren.
Warte mal, stopp.
Also, was du sagst, normalerweise hätte ich gedacht, das kommt an der Stelle, wo wir über die Gefahren
von solcher Datenzentralisierung sprechen.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt noch mal explizit fragen. Es ist also, diese Idee wird gerade, also in Deutschland gibt es das schon,
in Europa wird es gerade sozusagen angedacht gerade auf dem Weg. Und da ist einer von drei Punkten der Politik, dass da gesagt wird,
wir wollen auch, dass Unternehmen, die erst mal nicht offensichtlich was mit Medizin zu
tun haben, Zugriff auf diese Daten haben?
A. Indirekt schon. Also im Prinzip ist der europäische Gesundheitsdatenraum tatsächlich
nur einer von vielen Datenräumen. Es gibt Datenräume im Bereich Verkehr, es gibt Datenräume
im Bereich Handel oder sonstige Dinge. Man macht jetzt quasi an dem europäischen Gesundheitsdatenraum
ein Beispiel, wie könnte denn das im Digitalen gestaltet werden, dass es einerseits für
die Bürgerinnen gut ist, aber auch für die Wirtschaft und sonstige Dinge.
Und man nimmt quasi auch den Datenrahmen zuerst, weil er der komplizierteste ist, also allein
von dem Inhalt der Daten, weil man dann denkt, dass man halt das Prinzip schon einmal gut
durchexerziert hat und sagen kann, okay, jetzt kriegen wir Verkehrsdaten auch noch hin.
Und ich glaube, es ist einfach auch eine gewisse Realität, die wir jetzt vielleicht nicht angesprochen haben, aber,
das, was mit Medizin und Gesundheit zu tun hat, ist ein Markt.
Nicht nur im Sinne der Daten, also wenn man jetzt an die großen Datenkonzerne denkt, sondern das ist natürlich ein Hintergedanke, den man immer haben muss, den, glaube ich, auch alle wissen.
Heilung und so, das klingt immer gut, aber in Wahrheit ist es natürlich ein Markt.
Also ja, was mich gerade so ein bisschen irritiert ist Folgendes.
Gesundheitsdaten sind ja so, also Datenschutz ist ja immer ein großes Thema und dann sagt man Gesundheitsdaten ist, ich finde diese Unterscheidung schwierig, aber es sind besonders schützenswerte Daten.
Und ich hätte jetzt gedacht, okay, wenn man politisch vertreten will, dass man diese Daten, die ja besonders sensibel also sein könnten, an einer Stelle sammelt, dann macht man das, indem man sagt, die sollen natürlich nur für ganz bestimmte Zwecke benutzt werden.
Es werden nämlich Forschung, Abrechnungswesen und halt Pharma-Industrie, also schon sozusagen
Wirtschaft, aber im Sinne von, ist ganz konkret in diesem Bereich.
Ich wäre jetzt nicht auf die Idee gekommen, dass man als allererstes sagt, und dann machen
wir das auch noch für die Unternehmen auf, von denen wir als EU-Politikerinnen immer
sagen, wir brauchen mehr digitale Souveränität vor den großen amerikanischen Konzernen.
Aber das ist in dem grundlegenden Konzept mit drin?
Also ich glaube, man kann sich das wirklich vorstellen, wie das einfach das, also es gibt ja jetzt, ist auch unter dem DSA, also Digital Services Act, dieses Schnittstellengesetz von Social Media Plattformen.
Und man kann sich auch wirklich das EHDS vorstellen, wie eine riesengroße Schnittstelle, die sie bauen, wo sich dann jeder, der, weil das, also der bestimmte Bedingungen erfüllt, einfach andocken kann und die Daten absaugen kann und das dann für seine Zwecke benutzen kann.
Okay, dann möchte ich die Frage, die ich eigentlich gerade stellen wollte, nochmal
präzisieren. Es gibt also sozusagen drei Ziele für den EHDS.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine der Sachen, die ich in dieser Folge nicht mehr lernen werde.
Also für die EHDS gibt es also drei Ziele, nämlich den Primär und Sekundär und dann
sozusagen die Schnittstelle zur Freim… Das ist ja die Sekundäre.
Das wirft man einfach komplett alles in einem Korb. Okay, dann nochmal von Anfang an.
Haltet es für ein verfolgenswertes Ziel, diese Primärnutzung, also für PatientInnen quasi,
dass man das europäisch zentralisiert, also die Digitalisierung zentralisiert,
haltet es erstmal für ein Ziel, das man überhaupt verfolgen sollte?
Ist das was, wo man sagen kann, okay, beim EHDS müssen wir vielleicht über das Wie reden,
aber im Grunde genommen ist zu sagen, wir schaffen was, wo man in Europa,
wo Gesundheitsdaten einfacher verarbeitet werden können, das ist ein Ziel, das kann man erstmal haben.
Vielleicht zur Erklärung. Es gibt ja manche Themen im Digitalen, da sagt halt sozusagen der Club oder die Netzaktivistin der bestimmten Ausrichtung, die dem Datenschutz sozusagen zugewandt ist, sage ich es mal ganz subtil, wo sie sagen, das ist totaler Quatsch.
Also alles, was mit Vorratsspeicherung zu tun hat oder irgendwie Verschlüsselung aufmachen und kontrollieren, Chatkontrolle hatten wir in der Sendung, wo Khaleesi auch da war.
Da gibt es ja so ein ganz ganz prinzipielles so nein.
Einfach nein. So egal wie das ansteht, nein. Das ist meine Frage hier, glaube ich.
Gibt es bei diesen Zielen, die ihr gerade skizziert habt, gibt es dann kategorisches
nein oder sagt ihr, das kann man schon machen, man muss aber gucken wie?
BG'IN DR. Ich glaube nicht, dass man die Frage so stellen kann.
Ich muss sie so zurückweisen, denn es gibt hier nicht, es ist einfach nicht richtig,
die so zu stellen. Es gibt kein schwarz und weiß. Dann wir haben konkrete Vorschläge, wir haben konkrete Gesetze und du kannst sagen.
Das ist aber das, was ich gerade versucht habe zu fragen.
Es gibt nämlich bei manchen Stellen schwarz und weiß.
Und das war meine Frage. Es gibt es hier also nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es die in den meisten dieser digitalen Polit-Themen gibt, dass es
wirklich so schwarz und weiß ist, sondern du musst dir die Ausgestaltung schlicht ansehen.
Und dann musst du sagen, hey, findest du das noch akzeptabel?
Inwieweit müssen die Datengeber beteiligt werden oder nicht?
Inwieweit darf das kommerzialisiert werden? Ich finde es nicht zu spitzbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da auf der selben Ebene sind.
Weil wenn ich das jetzt umdrehe, wie ich es gefragt habe, dann sagst du gerade, also Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Staatsrohianer und Verschlüssungsaufbrechung sind denkbar, wenn man die Umsetzung gut genug macht.
Jetzt hast du die Extrembeispiele genommen.
Ja klar, genau. Das ist die Frage. Ist das so ein Extrembeispiel oder nicht?
Darf ich euch kurz unterbrechen? Ja bitte.
Danke. Also ich glaube, wir hatten das Thema auch schon mal, als wir über Registermodernisierung gesprochen haben, ganz, ganz anderer Tanzbereich.
Ja, aber Bianca hat es damals sehr schön gesagt und ich hatte es jetzt irgendwie auch als Beispiel eingeführt.
Es ist ja grundsätzlich, was du auch gesagt hast, in Spanien zum Zahnarzt zu gehen und dann wieder nach Deutschland zu kommen und dann das ganze Theater zu haben, was man dann halt so hat, ist natürlich super painfull und es ist uns glaube ich allen klar, dass es total wünschenswert wäre, wenn das.
Einfacher möglich wäre. So. Das kann man als Aussage grundsätzlich erstmal so hinstellen.
Wie wir das bewerkstelligen, ist eine völlig andere Frage und auch das größere Problem.
Okay, aber meine Frage war genau sozusagen, ist es so oder ist es vielleicht anders?
Wie ist es bei dem, wir wollen die Daten zentralisieren und zur Forschung zur Verfügung stellen?
Ist das auch was, wo ihr sagt, das kann man als Ziel verfolgen, wir müssen nur genau gucken, wie man es macht?
Zentralisieren heißt letztlich in diesem Fall vervielfachen.
Denn man holt die zusammen und bringt die in eine zentrale Stelle. Und da ist, glaube ich, der Konsens wesentlich geringer.
Denn das bringt mehr Nachteile als Vorteile. Man muss natürlich abwägen und ich glaube, die meisten Leute teilen irgendwie so Interesse von Forschenden
oder können verstehen, warum die einen möglichst großen Datenblob wollen. Aber die Zentralisierung birgt inhärente Risiken.
Und die sind vor allen Dingen mit der IT-Sicherheit verbunden und mit der Auflösung von Pseudonymen, das ist ja in der Regel ein Pseudonym, wie seht ihr Daten.
Und da hört es bei mir schon auf mit dem Konsens. Zumindest wenn man die Leute nicht fragt.
Denn es sind nun mal anders als andere Datenräume, die wir jetzt so ein bisschen beispielhaft hatten, sind ja nicht umsonst besonders sensible Daten.
Da geht es ja eben oft um schwerwiegende Krankheiten, da geht es um Stigmata, die sich damit verbinden.
Da ist meine Kompromissbereitschaft geringer als offenbar der Zeitgeist derzeit.
Also wir leben ja in so einer Welt, die glaube ich von dieser Pandemie geprägt ist und ich glaube die Befürwortung davon, dass man auch an echt großen Patientendaten forschen soll, ist größer geworden dadurch.
Einfach weil die Pandemie gezeigt hat, wie schlecht es im digitalen Gesundheitswesen aussieht.
Aber ich finde das überschießend zu sagen, okay, wir machen jetzt mal die fetten Datenbanken und wir fragen die Leute nicht mal, ob sie damit einverstanden sind, sogar wenn sie vielleicht seltene Krankheiten haben oder seltene Krankheitsverläufe und so. Da finde ich kurz bei mir mit dem Konzept auf.
Kann ich euch beide, Khaleesi, siehst du es genauso?
Also ja, ich sehe es tatsächlich genauso und ich glaube, wir haben halt auch in der Pandemie sehr prominente Beispiele dafür bekommen, wenn es um Tracing-Apps ging, dass zentralisierte Datensammlungen immer ziemlich fatal werden können, ziemlich schnell.
Also ich glaube, wir diskutieren immer sehr stark, auf wie weit man das noch in eigener Kontrolle behalten möchte.
Und das sehe ich bei diesem Ursprungskonzept vom EADS auf jeden Fall nicht, weil das war dann irgendwie so, wir haben einerseits den primären Nutzungszweck,
da hast du noch keine Kontrolle darüber, ob du den Säkulären nutzt und hast du gar keine, so war es zumindest ursprünglich mal angenacht.
Und ich glaube, da ist halt dieses, was Konstanze auch schon sagte, dieses drüber hinausschießen.
Also man hat erstmal keine Digitalisierung, man möchte dann plötzlich alles auf einmal mit Big Data und KI und sonstigen was und hat dann auch immer so eine Narrative,
wenn ich nicht sofort alles gleich bekomme, dann passiert irgendwas mit Menschen müssen sterben und sonstige Dinge.
Also die Narrative gibt es tatsächlich. Also ist mir tatsächlich mal passiert, dass ich auf einem Panel war und dann wurde ich von einem ehemaligen Gematik-Geschäftsführer beschimpft im Sinne von wegen euch sterben Menschen, weil ihr IT-Sicherheit macht.
Also, da sind die Narrative sehr überzogen, weil man jetzt, glaube ich, das Gefühl hat, man kann jetzt aus dem Impetus der Pandemie sehr, sehr weite Möglichkeiten sich einfordern, weil man eben die Leute das Gefühl haben, ja, okay, ohne Digitalisierung haben wir diese Pandemie gehabt, mit Digitalisierung hätten wir das nicht mehr, deswegen holen wir jetzt alles, was geht.
Und das ist auch exakt die Argumentation, die in dem Gerichtsverfahren, was ich persönlich.
Aber auch noch eine andere Person gegen die deutsche Gesetzgebung führe aktuell, immer vorgebracht wird.
Also die, die etwa, natürlich eine Menge Gutachten, die da abgegeben werden, da kommst
du am Ende immer zu einer Zuspitzung, dass dann die Forscher oder Unternehmen, die in
diesem Bereich tätig sind, sagen, also wenn wir hier Kompromisse machen in Bezug auf die
Die IT-Sicherheit oder den Datenschutz kostet quasi Menschenleben.
Also diese Zuspritzung ist immer als Argument drin und die erinnert mich natürlich an viele
andere Debatten in der Digitalisierung.
Genau und ich glaube, das ist auch wieder so ein interessanter Punkt.
Das ist ein, also ich sag mal, Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens und Lösung der Probleme,
die wir im Gesundheitswesen haben, ist ein, wie immer, ein sehr komplexes und auch gesellschaftlich komplexes Problem.
Und wir werden auch hier nicht mit, also in Anführungsstrichen, einfachen technischen Lösungen dafür sorgen, dass wir diese Problematik auflösen.
Also es ist ein Trend wirklich, also ich glaube der ist schon immer da, aber jetzt ist er besonders stark geworden, dass die Politik diesem Irrglauben folgt,
zu sagen, okay, ich hab ja dieses total komplexe Problem und es ist irgendwie, der Leidensdruck ist so hoch, das zu lösen, dass wir das jetzt unbedingt angehen müssen.
Und hier ist technologische Innovation und jetzt ist das Problem gelöst.
Okay, ich versuch mal zu sagen, bis zu der Stelle so einfach wirklich zusammenfasst und das ist, im Prinzip sagt ihr, also sagt ihr auch, nee, warte, stopp, nochmal zurück.
Also es gab eine Pandemie, daran hat man gesehen, sozusagen...
Wie in so vielen anderen Bereichen fällt mir auf, gerade auch sozusagen, es gibt sagen wir mal Nachholbedarf in was Gesundheitswesen und Digitalisierung.
Da müsste man mal was machen. Das ist also noch so Konsens. Ihr nickt alle sozusagen, könnt die Hörerinnen nicht sehen. Also Digitalisierung ja,
aber das was mit der Zentralisierung von Gesundheitsdaten gerade angedacht wird, das ist sozusagen
aufs andere Ende der Wippe gehen und dann in den Abgrund fallen, weil das ist ein bisschen viel sozusagen. Da gäbe es vielleicht nochmal Zwischenschritte.
Okay, es war schon angesprochen, es gibt da über die Art und Weise, wie diese Daten vorgehalten
und gesichert werden, gibt es Bedingungen, das würde ich gleich machen, aber vorher
nochmal erklären, den Unterschied zwischen Europa und Deutschland ein bisschen genauer.
Das dachte ich schon, Deutschland haben wir schon komplett verstanden, weil es gibt schon
ein Gesetz, wissen wir schon wie es ist, aber ich führe ein Gerichtsverfahren, das ist
natürlich ein sehr interessanter Satz in einer solchen Sendung.
Kannst du mal genau erklären, was für ein Gerichtsverfahren du führst?
Also das eine ist, das Gesetz ist in Deutschland nicht sehr bekannt. Das Digitale Versorgungsgesetz.
Einfach schlicht, weil es die Menschen ja nicht wirklich betrifft. Denn die Daten, die von den gesetzlichen Krankenversicherungen in ein Forschungsdatenzentrum fließen, über mehrere Schritte,
die haben ja eigentlich mit den Menschen nichts zu tun. Das läuft ja sozusagen unterm Radar.
Und das ist auch damals, als das beschlossen wurde, nicht sehr doll berichtet worden.
Und mich stört auch als Klägerin dagegen natürlich eine Tatsache besonders, nämlich
dass die Patienten nicht gefragt werden, die gesetzlich Versicherten.
Und das betrifft auch den anderen Kläger, der hat eine sehr stigmatisierende Krankheit
und bleibt deswegen auch anonym und hat auch einen anderen Gerichtsstand.
Also ich führe das Verfahren in Berlin, vom Sozialgericht und er ist in Frankfurt am Main.
Was genau beklagst du?
Okay, das hat natürlich mehrere Ebenen. Das eine ist, es gibt keine Form von Widerspruchsmöglichkeit und die haben wir versucht zu erkämpfen und haben wir auch schon in einem Vorverfahren des eigentlichen Verfahrens gewonnen.
Das heißt, meine eigenen Daten, meine als einzige von 73 Millionen gesetzlich Versicherten, werden nicht in dieses Forschungsdatacentrum übermittelt, aber das ist natürlich nur ein Zwischenschritt.
Denn eigentlich streben wir an europarechtliche Fragen.
Also tatsächliche Fragen, die mit der... Du bist vor Gericht und hast gesagt, ich klage dagegen, dass meine Daten verarbeitet werden, ohne dass ich gefragt werde. Das war die Klage.
Ja, ja. Aber natürlich greift das im Grunde das Gesetz an und die Art, wie diese Daten übertragen werden.
Aber da hat auch noch eine große Komponente, die sich auch im Gerichtsverfahren dann so ergeben hat, ist natürlich die IT-Sicherheit geworden.
Und die Frage, reicht die Pseudonymisierung, die Sie da vornehmen, die ist halt mehrstufig.
Sie haben überhaupt eine.
Okay, würde ich nachher noch sozusagen genau auseinander nehmen wollen.
Können wir gerne. Ist ein bisschen komplex so zu verstehen, aber wenn man es einmal durchblickt hat, ist es gar nicht so schwer.
Aber sie haben eine und man kann glaube ich mit guten Gründen und das ist halt auch meine Expertise darlegen, warum eine Pseudonymisierung von Gesundheitsdaten,
die auch sehr, ich würde mal sagen, vor allem über mehrere Jahre, aber die auch sehr präzise sein können und vielschichtig, warum man eine Pseudonymisierung so schwer machen kann.
Weil man nämlich durch den Zugriff auf andere Daten halten... Stopp!
Machen wir noch. Machen wir noch. Ich wollte erst mal nur wissen, Stand in Deutschland.
Stand in Deutschland, es gibt ein Gesetz und es gibt zwei Menschen, die dagegen klagen
und es sieht nicht so schlecht aus.
Es ist aber eine strategische Prozessführung, denn beides Mal sind wir unterstützt von
der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und deswegen ist der Fokus auch, das durchaus
europarechtlich aufzuhängen.
Da kommen wir jetzt zu. Was ist der Stand in Europa? Ist dieses EHDS...
Ne, ne, europarechtlich heißt nur, Regeln, die in Europa gelten.
Mit dem EHDS erstmal konkret nichts zu tun. Wenn wir aber gewinnen, haben sie was damit zu tun.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist nämlich ein Trick, wenn man nämlich jetzt so einen Präzedenzfall sozusagen hat und der auch europarechtlich festgehalten wird.
Zum Beispiel beim EuGH, dann.
Ist es nicht so, dass wir jetzt bei dem EHDS hingehen könnten und sagen können, es gibt aber eine gültige europäische Rechtsprechung, die sagt, dass ihr das so nicht machen könnt?
Also ihr klagt gegen ein Gesetz in Deutschland und weil wir in der EU sind, landet das im Zweifel vor einem europäischen Gericht.
Wenn das europäische Gericht sagt, dieser Fall in Deutschland wird so und so entschieden, dann hat das auch Auswirkungen auf...
So leicht ist es nicht. Du brauchst natürlich von einem Richter in Deutschland eine Vorlage.
Das heißt, ein Richter in Deutschland muss sagen, okay, in dieser Klage sind so viele schwerwiegende europarechtliche Fragen, dass ich sie dem Europäischen Gerichtshof vorlege.
Das ist unser Ziel. Das ist auch nicht geheim oder so, das steht in der Klage auch so drin.
Und wie es jetzt aussieht, es gab auch schon zwei mündliche Verhandlungen, ist der Richter am Sozialgericht durchaus aufgeschlossen, das auch so zu tun.
Aber in dem Berliner Fall ruht das Verfahren derzeit, weil die schlicht, die haben einfach technische Probleme.
Die sollen eigentlich seit letztem Oktober die Daten kriegen und dann ja auch darüber
entscheiden, wer und in welcher Form die nutzen darf. Also deine Daten?
Auch meine, aber die von 73 Millionen. Das Gericht soll die Daten kriegen?
Nein, nein, nein, das Forschungsdatenzentrum.
Achso, also ihr klagt gegen die Datenübertragung und die hat aber sozusagen noch nicht auf
eine Art und Weise stattgefunden, dass man die nachvollzieht?
Die sitzen schon auf den Daten zu einem großen Teil, aber sie haben es noch nicht technisch
hinbekommen sozusagen die Nutzungsberechtigten auch mit ja diese Daten auch rüberzureichen.
Also das ist also noch in einem Stadium technisch, wo sie es nicht hinkriegen, jetzt schon viele
Monate. Und da hat der Richter gesagt, was haben wir denn da eigentlich wirklich zu entscheiden?
Da fehlt so ein bisschen die Substanz. Und deswegen ein gutes Verfahren in Berlin.
A.
Okay, gut. Jetzt aber zum IHDS.
Was genau ist da der Stand in Europa? Gibt es da eine Gesetzgebungsinitiative? Gibt es eine Kommission, die sagt, lasst uns nochmal drüber nachdenken. Könnt ihr da genauer mal sagen, was passiert da gerade?
Also vielleicht erstmal nochmal mein Lieblingsthema EU Gesetzgebungsprozesse für Anfänger.
Sehr gerne. Vielleicht sollten wir dazu mal eine eigene Folge geben.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Das machen wir als nächstes auf Chaos Radio.
Das ist in Arbeit. Aber einmal ganz kurz, also EU-Gesetzgebung, die EU-Kommission hat Vorschlagsrecht und dann geht das an den Rat und an das Parlament.
Und das Interessante beim IHDS, deswegen ist das auch sehr untergegangen.
Stopp, weil ich selber immer durcheinander komme, muss ich immer fragen, ich weiß, der Vergleich hinkt, aber die Kommission ist sowas wie die Bundesregierung, der EU-Rat ist sowas wie der Bundesrat, also im Sinne von in der Kommission sitzen die EU-Minister, im Rat sitzen die, nein? Dann musst du nochmal erklären, weil ich verwechsel das jedes Mal.
Wollen wir vorverweisen?
Wir werden tatsächlich in der nächsten Folge genau darüber sprechen.
Also der Rat, da sind sozusagen die Länder drin und die haben auch eine, die Kurzform heißt Perm Raps, die haben eine permanente Repräsentation der Länder in Brüssel, die solche Dinge verhandeln.
Und dann gibt es auch so Unterarbeitsgruppen, bei der Töt-Kontrolle ist es zum Beispiel die Strafverfolgungsarbeitsgruppe, so.
Ja. Kommission ist?
Die Kommission ist im Prinzip die Regierung, das war schon richtig beschrieben. Der EU-Rat war falsch beschrieben. Genau. Aber, genau.
Okay, also mir hat das eh trotzdem geholfen, weil ich würde das, ist egal, ich würde es trotzdem so beschreiben.
Also genau, also ja, aber es ist ein bisschen anders, weil sozusagen der Rat sind Beamten.
Also das sind Beamten, die von der Hauptstadt sozusagen geschickt werden und die machen auch das, was die Hauptstadt sagt.
So kann man sich das eigentlich ganz gut vorstellen. Bundesrat hängt an den Regierungen der einzelnen EU-Mitgliedsländer.
Genau, das ist ja sozusagen, Bundesrat hängt ja auch an den Regierungen der… Nein?
Ich finde den Vergleich nicht sehr passend. Ich weiß, warum du ihn ziehst, aber der Bundesrat hat eine andere Funktion in der deutschen parlamentarischen Demokratie.
Also, ja, deutsche Demokratie machen wir dann auch nochmal irgendwann, aber auf jeden Fall.
Aber gerade Repräsentanz der Länder, Kommission, Regierung der EU quasi.
Genau, dann haben wir noch das Parlament. So, genau, und das Parlament. Und der Vorschlag zum EHDS ist am 3. Mai letztes Jahr rausgekommen. Relativ parallel.
Vorschlag der Kommission.
Die Kommission hat Vorschlagsrecht. Und das ist ein bisschen untergegangen, auch wegen der Chat-Kontrolle, ist aber eigentlich relativ ärgerlich, dass das so untergegangen ist.
Und im Prinzip würde ich sagen, wir sind mit dem, das EHDS ist ein bisschen schneller als die Chat-Kontrolle, also was ja dann passiert als nächstes, wenn die Kommission das vorgeschlagen hat,
wird es an Ausschüsse, also an fachspezifische Ausschüsse im Parlament gegeben, die das erstmal bearbeiten.
Das ist halt auch schon passiert und diese Ausschüsse geben dann einen sogenannten Bericht ab.
Das sind im Prinzip eine Liste an Änderungsvorschlägen zu diesem Gesetz.
Und die wird dann in dem Ausschuss abgestimmt und geht danach dann ans Parlament.
Und wir sind jetzt sozusagen an der Stelle, wo...
Wir einen Bericht haben, der aber noch nicht abgestimmt ist. Sozusagen.
Das heißt die ersten Änderungsvorschläge sind natürlich in Macht und die politische Debatte ist eigentlich losgegangen, wenn man es mal jetzt in line Terminus sagen will.
Und jetzt gibt es auch mehr Berichterstattung. Im Deutschen muss ich sagen relativ viel, aber es gibt auch in anderen Ländern einfach eine gewisse interessierte Presse.
Und ich glaube was auch interessant ist, das muss man auch mal dazu sagen, das wird ja auch im Rat verhandelt, aber der Rat, die machen halt so, wie halt so Beamtenhauptstadtansagen Sachen sind, da hat man relativ wenig Einsicht, außer es geht mal irgendwie ein sogenanntes Cable, also so ein Kabelbericht an die Hauptstadt verloren.
Was ist ein Drahtbericht?
Die sind eigentlich geheim und in vielen Gesetzgebungsverfahren sickern sie aber durch.
Das sind sozusagen, ich würde mal sagen, die diplomatischen Kanäle, deswegen heißen die
Drahtberichte wie früher, weil ich glaube, das kommt aus dieser Zeit, dieser Name.
Aber immer halt auch nicht, man weiß oft nicht, wie da inhaltlich die Verhandlungen
laufen und wer sich da auf welche Seite stellt.
Man weiß ab natürlich, wer die Regierungen sind, die da den meisten Einfluss haben, keine
Frage. Das ist diesmal interessant, weil...
Es gibt ein relativ großes Bündnis an Ländern, die wirklich sagen, sie haben wirklich Sorge, dass es irgendwie Privatsphäreimplikationen gibt und dass das problematisch sein könnte. So viel wissen wir auf jeden Fall.
Und das heißt, das wird jetzt auch sehr kontrovers dementsprechend im Rat unter diesem Motto diskutiert.
Es gibt noch eine Ebene, die da jetzt fehlt, die wir auch bei uns in der deutschen parlamentarischen Demokratie haben.
Nämlich in der Regel werden auch noch die zuständigen Stellen als Gutachter hinzugeholt.
Also etwa der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte. Also es gibt immer so Gutachten, die in diese politische Debatte reingereicht werden.
Die haben wir aber auch teilweise schon. Also das kommt immer noch dazu, wie wenn es bei uns auch hätte in den Ausschüssen.
Dann kann man die Sachverständigen oder der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte, das hat man in Europa ziemlich ähnlich.
Diese politische Debatte, die jetzt gerade stattfindet, die findet statt im Sinne von, da wird über Details verhandelt oder wird grundsätzlich verhandelt. Will man das oder will man das nicht?
Naja, also es gibt halt kein, also es gibt schon ein will man das nicht, will man das oder will man das nicht. Also wenn entweder das Parlament sagt, nö, wollen wir nicht. Oder der Rat sagt, wollen wir nicht. Dann würde das Gesetz scheitern.
Dafür müssen die aber erstmal diesen ganzen, wir arbeiten in unseren Fachausschüssen dazu, wir haben einen Report, es kommt zu einer Abstimmung im Ausschuss, es kommt zu einer Abstimmung im Parlamentkreis durchspielen.
Entschuldigung, ich habe unpräzise gefragt, was ich fragen wollte, eigentlich ist dieser
Ausschuss, das sind ja auch nach Parteiverteilung sozusagen versetzt, also da sind ja alle Parteien,
die Parlaments sind auch irgendwie drin und mir ist klar, der Ausschuss selber muss dann
irgendwas abgeben, wenn dann abgestimmt wird, aber und in der Parteienlandschaft sozusagen
arbeiten wir alle daran, wie machen wir das möglichst gut?
Oder gibt es da auch sozusagen Leute, die sagen, nee, lass mal lieber versuchen das Ganze abzuschießen?
Ich glaube, das ist eine voll schwierige Frage, weil bei EU Gesetzgebungsprozessen ist leider das Problem, es gibt so eine schöne Website, die heißt EU Legislative Train. Wenn so ein Gesetzgebungsprozess und so ein Gesetz erstmal rollt, dann rollt es.
Es gibt Gegenbeispiele, aber wirklich wenige. Wirklich sehr, sehr wenige.
Ja, wir haben gerade eins. Das ist nämlich die E-Privacy-Debatte. Aber normalerweise rollt es einfach.
Ist auch ein bisschen langfristiger als bei uns. Und die Vorstellung, die da gerade in deiner Frage drin rumschwankt,
nämlich, dass die Bundestagsfraktionen immer klar ist, dass sie so Positionen haben, die ist da oft nicht so.
Sie ist zwar ähnlich, also die finden sich ja auch in Fraktionen zusammen, aber es ist oft nicht so vorhersehbar,
wie wir das in der deutschen Demokratie haben, wo man immer schon weiß, die Liberalen werden diese Position haben
Und die Konservativen, die sind in Europa nicht so festgetan.
Ja, das liegt aber auch daran, das muss man vielleicht sagen, um so einen kleinen Europa-Background zu geben, dass halt zum Beispiel die Fraktion, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel die Sozialdemokraten nimmst, Sozialdemokraten in Schweden ist eine komplett andere politische Richtung teilweise sogar, als die Sozialdemokraten in Deutschland. Und dadurch kommt es auch zustande, dass diese Fraktionen keine eindeutigen Positionen haben.
Genau, ich will gar nicht weiter vorgreifen, damit wir sagen, nächste Folge noch was zu tun haben.
Was wichtig ist heute für uns zu verstehen, dieses Gesetz ist am Laufen und das heißt,
weil es anscheinend immer so ist und wie das genau ist, erfahrt ihr dann in der nächsten Folge,
wenn das an diesem Stand ist, wie wir es jetzt gerade haben, dann wird nur noch über das Wie geredet
und gar nicht mehr so sehr über das Ob.
Jein. Pfff. Hahaha. Okay.
Also leider sind EU-Sachen sehr komplex und es gibt nicht so richtig Schwarz-Weiß.
Könnte es natürlich auch, also ein Bericht eines Ausschusses kann natürlich auch so aussehen, dass sie einfach alle Artikel löschen.
Aber das ist momentan hier nicht abzusehen? Das ist momentan hier nicht abzusehen, aber nur so...
Wir merken uns für heute, die reden über das Wie.
Die Ausschüsse reden über das Wie. Und die sind auch relativ kritisch, also zumindest inhaltlich kritischer, als ich erwartet hätte.
Insbesondere zu einer Frage, zu der wir hier noch nicht gekommen sind.
Nämlich zu der Frage, wie sie sich stellen zu Opt-in, Opt-out.
Und ich glaube darüber müssen wir mal sprechen, weil das betrifft die deutsche Gesetzgebung
und aber die europäische natürlich auch und aber auch viele andere Datenvorhaben.
Da habe ich jetzt verstanden, in Deutschland ist sozusagen weder noch.
Ja, du hast keine Form von richtig. In Deutschland ist es so, das passiert einfach.
Richtig. Aber die fordern wir natürlich. Wie ist es dir beim EHDS gerade gedacht?
Und was ist die Variante, die ihr dann gut fändet? Es gibt total viele Varianten.
Wir gehen mal von der Ursprungslösung aus. Die Ursprungslösung war eigentlich, man muss glaube ich erstmal unterscheiden, also diese Primärnutzung, Sekundennutzung muss man glaube ich nochmal erklären.
Primärnutzung ist, von deinen Daten, du gehst irgendwie zum Arzt, zur Ärztin und irgendwie lässt du irgendwie ein Röntgenbild machen und hast Primärdaten generiert.
Und da geht es primär im EHDS dann darum, dass diese Daten irgendwie interoperabel nutzbar sind, Rezepte, sonstige Dinge. Das ist Primärnutzung von Daten.
Das ist auch vollkommen legitim, dass dein Arzt irgendwie deine Daten speiern kann, die er im Behandlungskontext erhoben hat.
Dann gibt es aber neben dieser ganzen Geschichte noch die Sekundärnutzung, die komplett davon losgelöst ist und dem Ursprungsentwurf gedacht war, es gibt eine Sekundärnutzung.
Alle größeren Kliniken und größeren Praxisverbünde und sonstige Dinge müssen ohne Einwilligung der Person und ohne Mitbestimmung der entsprechenden Leistungserbringer, wie es in Deutschland so schön heißt,
diese Daten für die sekundären Nutzen quasi übermitteln und freigeben, damit auf diesen Daten geforscht werden kann.
Das heißt, es ist quasi so ein bisschen wie in Deutschland mit dem Forschungsdatenzentrum, wo du als Patientin nicht dagegen dich wehren kannst.
Nur mal auf Europaebene nochmal mit dem, gebt mir bitte alle Daten, die ihr habt, ihr Kliniken und Sonstigen, wir machen damit jetzt quasi einen neuen, neuen, ja quasi per Gesetz definierten Datenabflusskanal, der automatisch läuft, bei dem man keine Möglichkeit mehr hat einzugreifen. Das ist der Ursprungsentwurf.
Also müssen wir es mal mal Zunge zergehen lassen, wir haben es drüber vorher nicht erwähnt. Das war, was da ursprünglich geplant war. Und auch kaum berichtet, also es war…
Und es geht halt auch viel weiter mit den Daten, die sie da abfließen lassen wollen, als in Deutschland, weil, das muss man auch immer beachten, in Europa ist die Lage, wie mit Gesundheitsdaten umgegangen wird und wie die erfasst werden, teilweise sehr heterogen.
Das heißt, so Thema Deutschland elektronische Patientenakte, wir diskutieren da noch drüber.
Es gibt natürlich auch Staaten, wo es das schon gibt und wo das Health Data Space dafür sorgen würde, dass es dann sozusagen elektronische Patientenakte im europäischen Datenraum geben würde.
Ich habe jetzt Bianca unterbrochen, ich wollte nur nochmal betonen, dass das die Idee war und kein Schwein hat am Anfang darüber debattiert.
Und die Idee war, wir machen es wie in Deutschland, okay.
In Deutschland ist das ja schon ein Gesetz gewesen. Ja, ja, eben, deswegen. Und dann?
Naja, jetzt ist man ja ein bisschen, also man hat erstmal erkannt, dass das ein Problem ist, wenn du da so einen Datenabflusskanal einbaust und in der Größe irgendwie, es ist quasi ein Europa-dimensionierter Datenraum mit 400 irgendwas Millionen Datensätzen.
Das bedeutet, sobald du irgendwie zum Arzt gehst, sobald irgendwie neue Daten anfallen, gehen die automatisch zur Sekundärnutzung irgendwo hin.
Ping! So, jetzt hat man aber festgestellt, das ist keine so ganz gute Idee, wir sollten mal drüber sprechen, über das Wie.
Und jetzt gibt's verschiedene Diskussionen, die sich wahlweise entwickeln in Richtung, man möchte ein Opt-out, also man möchte Möglichkeiten schaffen, dass Patientinnen sagen können, das möchte ich nicht mit diesen Daten.
Beziehungsweise es gibt auch Überlegungen, dass ich bei bestimmten Sachen explizit einwilligen muss. Das ist so gerade das, wo sich...
Das heißt Opt-in. Einwilligung heißt hier Opt-in.
Ich frage mich gerade, wie der Unterschied aussieht, weil Opt-in ist ja, ich willige ein.
Das heißt, wenn es passieren soll, muss ich gefragt werden.
Und wenn ich dann nichts sage, dann passiert auch nichts. Nur wenn ich explizit ja sage, dann passiert was.
Opt-out würde dann in dem Fall aber bedeuten, ich werde nicht gefragt, aber ich kann aktiv hingehen?
Ja.
Okay, das heißt man wäre dann davon, man wäre dann sozusagen, also ich stelle mir das für normale Patientinnen, die überhaupt nicht in dem Thema drin sind, die sich für so was nicht interessieren, ist ja opt-out dann sozusagen, also fast schon dasselbe wie…
Das hast du aber die Patientensicht. Du hast aber die Sicht derjenigen, die an die Daten ran wollen sehen. Die sehen das ganz anders.
Natürlich sehen die das ganz anders, aber das heißt dann wäre man darauf angewiesen, dass man einen netten Arzt hat, der sagt, liebe Patientin XY, wenn Sie heute nicht Nein sagen, dann werden diese Daten übermittelt. Anders geht das dann gar nicht.
Dann gar nicht. Oder ist das ObdOrt noch komplizierter gedacht?
Vor allen Dingen darf es nicht mit Zwang verbunden sein. Du denkst das ist zu praktisch, glaube ich.
Entschuldigung, ich denke das ist hier meine Aufgabe.
Nein, ich denke man hätte eine sehr viel verrechtlichere Lösung. Da kann nicht der
Arzt was aussuchen, sondern wenn man das vorschreibt per Gesetz, dann würde es ja
irgendeine Form geben, wie das tatsächlich dann praktisch im Krankenhaus oder beim Arzt passiert.
Oder bei der Apotheke. Cookie-Burners im Krankenhaus.
Nee, aber wie sähe denn ein Opt-out praktisch aus?
Ein Opt-out sähe im Prinzip so aus, dass es aufgrund von rechtlichen Grundlagen erstmal
so automatisch im Hintergrund läuft.
Das heißt, Menschen, die unter diese Rechtsprechung fallen, müssen automatisch diese Daten entsprechend
bei den Behandlungen übermitteln.
Außer du gehst aktiv als Patientin rein und irgendwie erklärst dich dieser Forschungsdatenstelle
zum Beispiel oder den Krankenkassen oder wem auch immer, die es dann für sich verwalten,
dass du das explizit nicht möchtest.
Dafür wird es im Formular gehen. Nein, aber ich versuche es wirklich praktisch zu verstehen.
Heißt es also?
Heißt das, meine Daten werden übermittelt und dann sage ich hinterher, ich will das aber gar nicht, dann werden sie wieder rausgelöscht?
Oder heißt das, ich muss irgendwo mal hingehen und sagen, ich will nicht, dass meine Daten übermittelt werden und dann kriege ich so ein Ping-Label-Achievement auf der Chipkarte und dann werden die Daten in Zukunft nicht mehr übermittelt?
Ich kann mir das sozusagen praktisch nicht vorstellen. Ja, Bianca hat über die Sekundärnutzung gesprochen. Wenn die irgendwo zusammengeführt werden, dann kriegst du nachher die Möglichkeit, nein zu sagen...
Aber das heißt, es passiert immer erst mal.
Nein, du hast jetzt aber ein Beispiel aus der Patientenakte eher genommen und hier geht's ja um die Zusammenführung bei der Sekundärnutzung.
Ja, ja, aber ich muss ja, also ja, ok. Also Sekundärnutzung habe ich verstanden, ist ja sozusagen nicht, sondern Sekundärnutzung ist ja meine Daten sind eh schon irgendwie da, wer darf da noch ran.
Ich versuche trotzdem zu verstehen, an welcher Stelle das dann ging, wie ginge. I don't get it.
Ich glaube, das ist aber eine sehr gute Frage, die du da stellst.
Weil die noch ungeklärt ist? Also technisch ist es komplizierter.
Das Thema ist ja auch ein bisschen, wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, bei der Sekundärnutzung, da musst du ja erst eine Infrastruktur bauen, die es ja noch nicht so ganz gibt.
Also es gibt jetzt die Infrastruktur über die Krankenkassen, wo wir quasi mit dem Forschungsdatenzentrum gerade in Deutschland sind.
Man müsste ja quasi auch noch eine Verbindung zu diesen ganzen Forschungsdatenzentren, die diese Daten zentralisieren, schaffen, dass die Leistungserbringer, Krankenhäuser, was auch immer, automatisiert ihre Daten dann entsprechend übermitteln können.
Da müsste man bei denen halt noch die Möglichkeit schaffen zu sagen, okay, jetzt gibt es irgendwie noch so einen Check, wenn Daten von Person xy betroffen sind, kann man nochmal checken, ob die Person xy irgendwie eine Art von Widerspruch hat, dann würde das nicht passieren.
Und das heißt, diese Infrastruktur ist ja auch, also das ist auch das, was der IADS auch immer in der Implementierung macht.
Es gibt so technische Rahmenwerke, die da sagen, wie das grundsätzlich funktionieren soll.
Das ist ja quasi noch im Aufbau. Das hängt auch zusammen mit dem Umbau der elektronischen Patientenakte,
die ja auch gerade in die Richtung geht, okay, du kriegst automatisch eine, du kriegst die befüllt,
du kriegst die Zugriffe von den Leistungserbringungen drauf und als vierte Stufe eben, was machst du mit Forschungsdaten.
Und das ist in der Ausgestaltung noch so ein bisschen spannend, weil diese Daten automatisch
irgendwo hinfließen zu lassen, die in der elektronischen Patientennetze eigentlich irgendwie
verschlüsselt sind und besonders gesichert, dass sie eben nur für die Patientinnen zur
Verfügung stehen, dann automatisch irgendwohin abfließen zu lassen, ist halt nochmal eine
ganz eigene Infrastruktur.
Aber wir versuchen nur die Ebenen auseinanderzuhalten und sie trotzdem zusammen zu denken, weil
sie ja nochmal zusammen gedacht werden müssen.
In meinem Kopf geht sich gerade der totale Knoten, weil für mich klingt das ein bisschen
Also es gibt entweder Opt-in, dann muss die Entscheidung halt sozusagen an der Stelle
stattfinden, wo die Datenbetagung stattfindet, oder es gibt Opt-out, aber das bedeutet relativ
wahrscheinlich praktisch.
Dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Also ich krieg das immer im Kopf.
Guck, du kannst es technisch bauen.
Du musst es unterschiedlich bauen. Aber du musst eh diese Möglichkeit einbeziehen,
denn nach dem europäischen Datenschutzrecht hat sowieso jeder auch die Möglichkeit der Einsichtnahme.
Du musst Daten löschen können. Also du brauchst diesen Kanal technisch sowieso.
Es ist wahrscheinlich technisch einfacher, sich eine Opt-in-Lösung zu denken.
Aber Verzeihung, das ist nicht unbedingt die Kategorie, in der wir hier denken müssen,
müssen, was einfacher zu bauen ist. Zumal wenn das für einen sehr langfristigen Zeitraum
sind, der alles immer viele Jahre, die die Daten da festhalten wollen, gedacht ist.
A. Aber habt ihr eine präferierte Lösung, wenn ihr jetzt Opt-in, Opt-out?
B. Opt-in.
A. Ja, genau. Mein Verdacht wäre gewesen, ihr findet Opt-in geiler als Opt-out, weil
Opt-in sozusagen überlässt die Entscheidung immer sozusagen konkret beim Betroffenen.
Aber du klangst gerade so wie, vielleicht ist Obd auch eine ganz gute Idee, aber ist nicht das so?
Diese Eindruck ist falsch. Also ich finde das auch einfach von der Frage, wie informiert ein Patient sein muss.
Und für den Aufwand, den auch Leute, die daran forschen wollen, zu betreiben haben, für ein Obd hin viel besser.
Aber ich habe natürlich jetzt sehr viele Stellungnahmen gelesen im Rahmen des Gerichtsverfahrens,
was dagegen spricht aus Sicht der Medizinforscher oder der Leute, die in diesem industriellen Bereich tätig sind.
Tätig sind. Natürlich stört die das enorm, weil sie wissen, dass es sehr viel weniger Menschen sind, deren Daten sie dann da verarbeiten können, weil einfach die Trägheit ist groß und es ist auch in anderen Datenbereichen sehr gut beforscht, wie wenig Leute dann dabei sind.
Und ich glaube aber, wir kommen hier an einen sehr wichtigen Punkt zu deiner Anfangsfrage, ob wir prinzipiell dagegen sind, was zum Beispiel jetzt diese Primärnutzungszwecke angeht, weil das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz grundsätzliches Problem bei Digitalisierung in Deutschland, aber auch bei Digitalisierungsfragen international und da ist In-Opt-Out das beste Beispiel.
Wir wollen ja nicht, dass irgendwie fünf versprengte Hacker die Möglichkeit haben, informationelle Selbstbestimmung auszuüben. Wäre auch was, aber…
Wäre auch was, aber das ist ja nicht das Ziel. Unser Ziel bei Digitalisierung ist ja, klar, wir wollen irgendwie einen gewissen Zugewinn an Convenience haben, aber wir wollen auch, dass alle informationelle Selbstbestimmung haben.
Und dass das auch irgendwie für jeden, egal wie wenig, digital Wissen.
Er oder sie hat, möglich ist, zu sagen, ich kann immer noch alles auf Papier machen und es sorgt irgendwie nicht dafür, dass es einen Datenabfluss ohnegleichen gibt und ich gar nichts dagegen machen kann, sondern dass ich wirklich der Herr über meinen Daten sein kann, egal wie viel oder wenig technisches Wissen ich mitbringe.
Und ich glaube, das ist extrem wichtig, in all diesen Diskussionen immer zu beobachten, herzunehmen und zu sagen, es muss für alle möglich sein und nicht nur für Leute, die Expertise haben.
Verstanden. Klingt einleuchtend. Ich würde dann jetzt zur Sicherheit, zur Datensicherheit kommen können. Es gibt noch die beiden Themen Pseudonymisierung und generelle IT-Sicherheit.
Wo bist du heute, Nerd? Ich werde sie dir auch noch ansprechen.
Haha. Ich meine, es ist schon das Chaosradio. Also das Ziel ist ja immer, wir fangen am Anfang an, aber am Ende sind wir auch so ein bisschen im Rabbit Hole drin.
Deswegen, wie rum muss man es jetzt machen? Vielleicht erstmal Pseudonymisierung.
Pseudonymisierung, soweit ich es kenne, ist nicht Anonymisierung, sondern heißt, plastisch gesagt, an den Daten steht nicht mehr mein Name dran.
Aber meine Daten sind immer unterscheidbar von allen anderen Daten und sind immer sozusagen, also ich weiß, die gehören zu einem, die gehören zu einer Person.
Also beim Krankendatensatz gibt es eine, also wie ich es verstanden habe, gibt es dann sozusagen meinen Datensatz.
Da steht aber nicht mehr Markus Richter dran, sondern halt irgendeine komische Zahlenfolge. Ist das Polynomisierung?
Wir lassen mal Bianca die Definition machen, die stimmt natürlich so nicht, da sind ein paar Fehler drin.
Wieso das denn? Warum?
Naja, weil... Du wolltest Bianca lassen, ich sag's dir. Ja, ich wollte Bianca lassen.
Also bei Pseudonymisierung ist im Prinzip so, du versuchst einen Datensatz, der ist in Klarnamen auf dich beziehbar, ist eindeutig personenbeziehbar, versuchst du Personenbezug durch ein Pseudonym zu ersetzen.
Das kann jetzt zum Beispiel sein, dass du, um dein Beispiel aufzugreifen, jetzt hat man irgendwie deine, nehmen wir mal ein Blutbild.
Da ist vorher dein Name dran oder irgendwie zum Beispiel auch deine Krankenversicherungsnummer oder was haben wir noch? Irgendwelche Dinge, die dir eindeutig zuordnenbar sind. DNA.
DNA. Irgendsowas. Also ein eindeutiges Merkmal. Dann versucht man diese eindeutigen Personenbeziehungen zu ersetzen durch ein gewürfeltes Pseudonym.
Also kriegst du dann irgendwie eine zufällige Nummer, die man dann auch nicht mehr hochzählen kann, dass man jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr weiß, dass die Krankenversicherungsnummer plus eins zu deiner irgendwie logisch dann next bis, und man würfelt das ein bisschen durch.
Also eigentlich sind diese Pseudonyme auch nicht mehr logisch nachvollziehbar in irgendeiner Reihe zu dem vorherigen.
Das heißt, man muss natürlich, wenn man jetzt das wieder zurückrechnen möchte, irgendwo diese Pseudonyme vorhalten.
Das macht man ja in diesem Forschungsdatenzentrum das Thema auch, das kann Konstant noch genauer erklären.
Und das ist erstmal Pseudonymisierung. T. Top, habe ich eine Frage.
Das heißt, in einer Datenbank stehen die Daten mit dem Pseudonym und in einer anderen
getrennt steht die Verbindung, welches Pseudonym gehört zu welchem Namen.
So habe ich dich gerade verstanden, Bianca. B. Sollte halt nicht dieselbe Stelle sein, nicht wahr?
T. Sollte nicht dieselbe Stelle sein, aber es gibt beide Datensätze, aber sie sind getrennt.
B. In Deutschland ist es ein bisschen komplexer, aber im Prinzip ja.
T. Im Prinzip ist das die Idee. Die andere Frage, die ich habe, ist, also am klassischen Beispiel, ich gehe ja zu
vielen Ärzten. Gibt es ein Pseudonym, das immer wieder vergeben ist?
Oder hat mein Hausarzt und sozusagen die Daten von meinem Hausarzt bekommen ein
anderes Pseudonym als die Daten von meinem, ich denke mir mal,
oder was total Wildes aus Sportarzt.
Also gibt es in diesem Datensatz meine gesamte Krankenakte mit einem und demselben Pseudonym oder gibt es für verschiedene Dinge verschiedene Pseudonyme, die aber auf mich zurückführbar sind?
Also wir gehen mal von dem aus, was das Zielbild ist, von dem was auch mit Forschungsdatenzentrum und zukünftigen Gesetzesvorhaben auch das Ziel ist.
Ziel ist eigentlich unter allem, als Mehrwinger von einer Pseudonym-Krankenakte auch quasi querverweise fragen zu können.
Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie sage, okay, ich mache erst eine Studie über Bluthochdruck, dann möchte ich dann irgendwie noch Querbeziehungen haben zu Alipositas oder so.
Und das heißt, es ist eigentlich ein Pseudonym für alles über den gesamten Datensatz.
Man könnte es natürlich auch anders machen, man macht es für verschiedene Sektoren, verschiedene Pseudonyme, wo man dann nochmal eine getrennte Datenbank hat, dass diese Kreuztabellen irgendwo verfügbar sind.
Aber eigentlich ist der Gedanke tatsächlich in der medizinischen Forschung, dass ich das, was Mediziner mir immer total vorbieten, als Fachbegriff longitudinale Krankheitsverläufe habe, also über das gesamte Leben hinweg, dass ich das unter einem Pseudonym quasi habe.
Die meinen das auch wirklich lang. In Deutschland ist das etwa 30 Jahre. Aber du hast natürlich praktische Probleme. Du stellst dir jetzt vor, du wechselst nicht die Krankenkasse oder so.
Da gibt es natürlich technisch praktische Probleme.
Jemand wechselt die Krankenkasse, dann muss das schon zusammenführen.
Aber im Wesentlichen ist die Argumentation auch, du möchtest natürlich möglichst langfristig forschen können.
Das heißt, du willst vielleicht mal gucken, wie war es vor 25 Jahren bei demselben Menschen,
den du aber natürlich nicht namentlich, also nicht mit seinem Plan haben.
Das ist ein ganz starkes Argument, kommt immer. Ist auch in meinem Fall so.
Also ich finde das jetzt sagen, also jetzt mal, wir haben ja keine Mediziner in hier,
aber sozusagen aus, ich finde das erst, das klingt erstmal plausibel, also wenn ich diese
Daten habe, dann möchte ich sozusagen auch immer einen Datensatz, der einem konkreten
Menschen entspricht, im Sinne von, um genau so eine Forschung machen zu können, weil
das vielleicht nicht gab.
Ja, es mag sein, dass sie dann in der Praxis bilden, die vielleicht gehorten, weil sie was anderes forschen wollen oder so, aber es gibt auch viele Fälle, die haben auch immer unglaublich viele Einzelfälle, die sie dann heranziehen, wo man das möchte.
Also wo die Forschungsfrage auch genau so konzipiert ist oder eben auch eine Langfristforschung sein soll. Da kann man sich auch als Laie viele Beispiele vorstellen.
Ich finde das auch ganz interessant, weil bei diesen Diskussionen, finde ich, ist es immer spannend auch zu wissen, okay, dieser eine Nuxusansatz, der da präsentiert wird, der hat tatsächlich Hand und Fuß und ist nicht sozusagen was Ausgedachtes, um was anderes umzusetzen.
Und das Interessante ist, weil es ja ein europäisches Gesetz ist und ich hatte das ja gesagt, es gibt eine gewisse Heterogenität, wie Gesundheitsdaten funktionieren und es gibt natürlich auch europäische Länder, die solche Unique Identifier, also die da auch zum Beispiel benutzt werden könnten, schon benutzen.
Also wo deine Krankenakte an eine eindeutig identifizierbare Nummer schon geknüpft ist.
Aber eine gewisse Heterogenität ist glaube ich die Untertreibung des Jahrzehnts. Natürlich.
Aber in Europa gibt es echt einen Zoo. Einen Zoo, genau.
An Umgang mit Gesundheitsdaten, mit Identitäten, alles mögliche.
Aber darauf wollte ich jetzt nicht eingehen. Ich fand es so lustig, eine gewisse Heterogenität.
Okay, wir müssen noch eine Frage zum Pseudonym haben.
Beim Pseudonym und dann glaube ich, wenn man treue Chaos-Radiohörerin ist, dann hat man das möglicherweise mitbekommen,
das ein grundlegendes Problem bei Pseudonymisierung ist, wenn...
Die Daten, die gesammelt werden, einem einzelnen Menschen entsprechen, dann gibt es manchmal
eine Ansammlung von Merkmalen, aus denen ich dann sozusagen zurückfolgern kann, wer das ist.
A. Du bist besonders stark bei Gesundheitsdaten, korrekt.
B. Okay, gut. Sehen die GesetzgeberInnen, die da gerade verhandeln, das Problem und
wird das irgendwie verargumentiert?
Also die Kommission hat ja offensichtlich diesen Vorschlag gemacht und hält das für eine gute Idee. Wenn wir uns jetzt aber angucken, was in den Änderungsanträgen der einzelnen Ausschüsse passiert ist, würde ich sagen, die Antwort ist ja.
Also von, also und das ist wirklich interessant, das ist auch wirklich der gesamte Strauß an allen politischen Gruppen, die sagen, sie sehen da ein Problem und sie möchten irgendwie daran arbeiten, das zu lösen. Die einen in die eine Richtung und die anderen in die andere Richtung, aber die ist da.
Gibt es denn da, also ich stelle mir das schwierig vor sozusagen, weil wenn das Ziel ist sozusagen, wir möchten, dass die Daten möglichst konkreten Personen entsprechen für die Forschung, dann laufe ich direkt in diese Probleme rein. Gibt es da Ansätze? Kann man die Daten irgendwie verweichlichen oder dekonkretisieren oder was? Keine Ahnung, was man da machen kann.
Also es gibt, glaube ich, es gibt keine magische technische Lösung, die alle Probleme löst.
Es gibt immer so Lösungen, die können in bestimmten Bereichen Risiken minimieren.
Aber es gibt nicht so diese magische Lösung, die für alle Anwendungsfälle funktioniert.
Weil du es mit Verweichlichen gesagt hast, es gibt so Verfahren wie Differential Privacy, da werden Daten bewusst verrauscht, das heißt man macht dann so Rundungen und guckt, dass man aufgrund von den Rundungen keine eindeutige Nachvollziehbarkeit mehr von diesen Daten hat, weil die Daten dann einfach in dieser Rundung untergehen.
Das hat aber dann zum Beispiel den Nachteil, dass man das dann manche bewusst sagen, ja dann habe ich keine präzisen Daten mehr, dann kann ich keine präzisen Forschungen mehr machen. Dann gibt es irgendwie so Sachen wie Verschlüsselung, also auf verschlüsselten Daten forschen, Multi-Party Computation, sonstige Dinge.
Und ich glaube bei vielen Sachen ist natürlich auch die Frage, also Gesundheitsdaten sind ja auch dann häufig besonders kritisch, wenn es um Krankheitsbilder geht, die besonders selten sind.
Wenn halt nur drei Menschen diese Krankheit haben und du das sozusagen in so einen Pott speist und mischt und nur sozusagen das Ausgerechnete am Ende raushaust,
würdest du sagen, ja kannst du halt relativ einfach einen Rückschluss darauf ziehen, welche drei Menschen das sind.
Das ist natürlich ein Problem, das dann auftaucht, obwohl dieses Konzept theoretisch das verschleiern sollte.
Ich würde da noch mal ansetzen wollen. Also Bianca hat jetzt ein paar konkrete Beispiele genannt.
Also wie gute, auch massenweise, also milliardenfach eingesetzte Ansätze gibt.
Differential Privacy wäre eins, die man nehmen könnte.
Aber sie hat auch genau das Problem benannt, was auch sofort immer als Gegenargument kommt.
Wenn du kannst dir immer irgendeinen Einzelfall aus dem allerwertesten ziehen, wo dieses spezielle Verfahren, was du gerade besprichst, zum Beispiel Differential Privacy, dein konkrete Forschungsproblem irgendwie entweder erschwert oder auch nichtichtmacht.
Das heißt, du hast kein Verfahren, was alles wunderbar erschlagen würde. Und damit kommen sie dann auch argumentativ immer.
Weil natürlich so ein, also der medizinische Forscher oder der, der.
Also der mit dem kommerziellen Bereich forschen will, der sucht ja auch meistens gerade diese Fälle.
Also das ist ein interessantes Phänomen, dass es technische Lösungen gibt, auch solche, die lange im Einsatz sind, die gut beforscht sind und so.
Aber die haben halt nie dieses absolute, vollständige Problemlösen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ja sozusagen wirklich, das ist ja tatsächlich ein klassisches Dilemma oder das geht ja einfach nicht.
Eben und das anzuerkennen fällt aber vielen ganz durch schwer, weil diese medizinischen Forschungen immer sofort mit Leben und Tod kommen und das ist nach der Pandemie jetzt auch stärker geworden.
Man muss ja sagen, wir haben jetzt mit der Pandemie immer so ein bisschen argumentiert und dass der Wunsch danach, anders und besser zu forschen, dadurch verstärkt wurde.
Aber die Wahrheit ist natürlich, dass die Idee ein bisschen älter ist als die Pandemie, ne?
Das war jetzt nur sozusagen ein wohlfreiler Anlass. Aber da hat sich was verschoben. Ich finde aber den Anspruch, dass man irgendeine Form von Privacy-Enhancing-Technologie findet. Also bei unserem Verfahren wird sehr viel über Differential Privacy gestritten.
Dass man die findet und damit alle Probleme löst, finde ich infam. Weil da fällt ja völlig diese Abwägung weg, die man treffen muss. Weil der verschiedene schützenswerte Güter gibt, die man hier abzuwägen hat.
Und irgendwie wird den Technikern dann immer die Aufgabe gestellt, ey, jetzt macht das aber mal so, dass das jetzt schon aber wirklich alles und toll erschlägt. Finde ich unmöglich.
Aber ich möchte jetzt wirklich eine Lösung von euch, aber sozusagen keine technische, sondern die Frage, gibt es denn, jetzt haben wir, also wir haben ja zwei Sachen jetzt gerade gesprochen, also das In-Opt-In-Opt-Out und jetzt eben die Pseudonymisierung.
Erstmal nur auf diese beiden Säulen betrachtet, sagen, gibt es da eine Forderung, die man daraus ableiten kann, die ihr unterschreiben würdet?
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man sagt, okay, wir anerkennen, dass man mit den
konkreten Daten forschen will und dass es keine perfekte technische Lösung gibt, deswegen
sagen, könnt ihr machen, aber mit Opt-in.
Das ist nur ein ausgedachter Impuls, den ich in meinem Kopf habe.
Meine Frage an euch ist, gibt es eine konkrete Forderung, wo ihr sagt, an den EHDS würden
wir uns wünschen, dass es auf die Art und Weise funktioniert?
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder so eine Zuspitzung, die du da machst. Ja, natürlich.
Also, okay, dann müssen wir über IT-Sicherheit eigentlich sprechen und welche Maßnahmen wir fordern würden.
Die zusätzlich sind zu der Frage dieser Widerspruchsrechte.
Denn egal, ob du Opt-in, Opt-out hast oder aber gar keinen Opt-in, Opt-out,
Du hast es IT-sicherheitsmäßig so zu sichern, dass nicht Hinz und Kunz und seine Schwester irgendwie ein Datenreichtum haben.
Denn wir haben ja parallel auch eine IT-Sicherheitskrise. Und die drückt sich auch geradeaus in Fragen von gehackten Gesundheitsdaten.
Und das zu adressieren, das hängt zusammen, aber es sind auch teilweise explizit andere Forderungen, die hier zu stellen sind.
Ich würde Bianca gerne noch hören. Der Gesichtsausdruck war so wie...
Interessante Frage, aber ich weiß nicht so genau.
Also ich glaube, das ist das Grundproblem, was wir haben. Also diese Universallösungen, die wir immer so haben. Wir wollen technische Universallösungen, wir wollen irgendwie so die zentrale Datensammelstelle, weil die ist einfach und convenient.
Ich glaube, wir haben für vieles, brauchen wir so den Möglichkeitenraum, den wir Leuten auch irgendwie bieten. Das ist bei Opt-in und Opt-out das Szenario. Also es gibt Menschen, die möchten, die sagen, ja macht mit deinen Daten, was ihr wollt.
Ich habe den universal Zustimmung von mir und es gibt Menschen, die möchten sehr, sehr differenziert genau gucken, was sie machen möchten.
Aber wir kriegen immer so diese, wir kriegen nur eine Lösung, wir müssen uns auf eine Lösung einigen, die soll für alles funktionieren.
Das kann ja nicht funktionieren, weil Menschen sind ja auch in der Art und Weise, wie sie mit Gesundheitsdaten sich ausdrücken und artikulieren wollen, ganz anders.
So ist es, glaube ich, auch bei der technischen Fragestellung. Also es gibt, glaube ich, für bestimmte Szenarien Lösungen für den Einzelfall, aber es gibt keine universelle für vieles. Und das ist, glaube ich, bei vielen Dingen, wo man das Gefühl, also im Gesundheitsthema gerade so dieses, man will eine schnelle Lösung für alles machen.
Aber man muss anerkennen, dass es verschiedene Möglichkeiten für verschiedene Zwecke braucht.
Und dass man manchmal auch sehr stark die Patientin miteinbeziehen muss und sie fragen muss, wie möchtest du das eigentlich?
Folgende Risiken sind dabei, das sind die Chancen.
Und wenn du nicht damit zurechtkommst, dann wird es jetzt leider in technischen Tiefen nicht erklären können.
Hier sind Empfehlungen von neutralen Organisationen zum Beispiel, die sagen.
Gut, wir haben uns das mal angeguckt. Technisches Risiko ist vertretbar, beziehungsweise gar nicht vertretbar. Das sind ja so Mitteldinge auch immer, weil die Vorstellung, die immer kommt, ist, wenn du das so kompliziert machst mit dieser Mitbestimmung, dann versteht das ja kein Mensch mehr. Also machen wir das einfach für euch.
A. Ich habe noch eine Detailfrage und zwar, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen so, als ob man
nicht nur opt in, opt out, sondern auch opt in, aber dann mit. Ich habe noch eine Frage
zu dieser Pseudonymisierung. Die, wie heißt das, differential?
B. Differential privacy. A. Differential privacy funktioniert doch nur, wenn da alle mitmachen. Oder geht das
auch sozusagen, manche Daten werden verrauscht und manche nicht, geht das?
Nee, du willst das eigentlich über den Datenbestand machen, den du gerade nutzen willst.
Also das wäre kein Weg zu sagen, du kannst ganz einwirken oder du kannst sagen, ja, aber verrauscht.
Also wenn du Daten rausgibst, etwa an den, der nutzungsberechtigt ist, der einen Antrag gestellt hat und der kriegt einen fetten Block Daten, dann kannst du das Verfahren nutzen. Nein, nein, nein.
Die Frage war, ob wir sagen, also du schmeißt gerade zwei Sachen durcheinander, also für uns…
Oder ich bringe sie zusammen.
Ja, oder du bringst sie zusammen. Das könnte eine sehr schlechte Idee sein, weil man sollte seine Parlamentarier nicht unbeaufsichtigt lassen und sie sollte sie auch tunichst nicht auf solche Ideen bringen. Okay.
Also, ich verstehe… Stopp. Es war erst mal nur eine Frage, wie ist das technisch?
Meine Frage ist eigentlich die, wenn ich einen Datensatz habe, wo verschiedene Menschen daran
beteiligt sind, ist es dann technisch sinnhaft zu sagen, ein paar von denen verrauschen und ein paar nicht?
Oder? Also, wenn wir von einem Konzept ausgehen, was wir auf Privacy by Design auslegen wollen,
dann wollen wir das per Default komplett immer so machen.
Da stellen wir auch gar nicht die Frage, ob nein oder ja. Da widerspricht ihr euch sozusagen selber, aber ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, die Leute
wollen verschiedene Auswahlmöglichkeiten haben, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dazu
zählt halt auch, dass ich sage, bitte nehmt meine Daten und nehmt den Datensatz auch so
konkret, wie es geht.
Okay, warte mal, da müssen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, was ist der Sinn von Differential Privacy damit?
Man muss sich mal klar machen, was das soll. Das ist eine von verschiedenen technischen Möglichkeiten, um dieses De-anonymisieren
möglichst wirksam zu erschweren.
Das ist das Ziel von Differential Privacy. Also zu sagen, ihr käppchen fetten Blob an Daten und ihr könnt nicht...
Einen anderen riesen Datendatz dagegen laufen lassen, um Leute zu de-anonymisieren. Das wäre der Zweck der Übung.
Und ich glaube, deine Frage zählt auf ein anderes, oder?
Ja. Ne, meine Frage zählt darauf, in diesem Blob könnte es da auch Daten geben, die man de-anonymisieren kann oder welche, die man nicht de-anonymisieren kann.
Also die Argumentationskette von Markus ist, für Forscher ist ja sozusagen, je mehr sie wissen über die Personen, desto besser.
Und je genauer die Daten sind, desto besser. Und wenn wir über Opt-in sprechen, ob es sinnvoll möglich ist, zu sagen, ich mache ein generelles Opt-in, aber auch ein Opt-in dafür, dass sozusagen in Klarnamensmanier meine Daten übermittelt werden, weil das ja besser ist für die Forschung. Also sozusagen eine Datenspende in großen Anführungszeichen.
Na gut, sowas gibt es natürlich heute auch. Es gibt viele Forscher, die gerade bei seitlichen Krankheiten oder spezifischen Krankheiten auch heute Patienten explizit fragen.
Dann sind das auch nicht pseudonymisierte Daten. Das gibt es ja.
Aber das kann man nicht zusammen...
Ich glaube, ich erkläre meine Frage anscheinend nicht gut genug. Vielleicht bin ich auch schon zu lange hier beim Chaos dabei. Meine Frage ist folgendes.
Es gibt, ich mache es mal ganz konkret, es gibt 50 Leute. 50 Leute haben ihre Datensätze.
Diese Datensätze werden pseudonymisiert.
So und jetzt von dem was ich von Bianca verstanden habe ist folgendes,
wenn ich diese Datensätze verrausche, dann wird es schwieriger aus diesen 50 Leuten
auf die konkreten 50 Einzelpersonen zurückzukommen. Nein, das sollte unmöglich sein sogar.
Okay, so jetzt ist meine Frage folgende.
Es gibt diesen Datensatz und das Verrauschen habe ich so verstanden,
Die einzelnen Datensätze werden verrauscht. Es gibt von diesen 50 Leuten 25, die sagen, wir wollen es verrauschen. Und die anderen 25 sagen, wir wollen es nicht.
Die Frage ist... Achso, du willst die Leute spezifisch fragen. Wir müssen ihnen aber vorher erklären, was differential privacy ist.
Genau. Und meine Frage ist jetzt, sinkt dadurch der Pseudonymisierungsschutz für die 25, die verrauschen wollen, weil die Gesamtmenge der Verrauscher kleiner wird?
Dann ist deine Frage eigentlich nach der Skalierbarkeit. Differential Privacy hat zu tun mit der Menge der Daten.
Die Güte der Verrauschung hat mit der Menge der Daten zu tun. Alles klar, danke.
Aber du willst nicht ernsthaft, aber der Hintergrund der Frage ist, du möchtest Menschen, glaube,
ich, schon gerne, wenn sie krank sind, willst du die wirklich mit einfachen Fragen beschäftigen?
Du willst doch nicht jemanden, der gerade eine Krankengeschichte hat, mit wirklich technisch
anspruchsvollen Fragen irgendwie belästigen, oder? Also ich würde es nicht wollen.
Stopp, ich hatte euch so verstanden, dass das ein Ziel ist, dass es dich aus dem Akküren geht.
Nein, nein, nein. Das war's.
Bjarke, ich hatte dich so verstanden. Ne, andersrum. Ich muss nochmal erklären, wie das eigentlich in der Praxis funktionieren können soll.
Es gibt ja so diese einfachen Fragen, wo man möchte, möchtest du Forschung? Ja, nein.
Aber das ist ja keine Ja-Nein-Frage, sondern es sind verschiedene Stufen, die man begehen kann.
Also es gibt so diese Daten sind anonym, weil es sind zum Beispiel, die sind nur in Hunderterstücken irgendwie in Kohorten zusammengefasst.
Da kann man dann davon ausgehen. Ich muss mal kurz erklären, was sind Kohorte?
Quasi in eine Gruppe von Personen zusammengefasst nach irgendwelchen Eigenschaften. Also irgendwie Menschen im Alter von 50 bis 55, die alle irgendwie eine bestimmte Krankheit haben und so.
Die in der Summe halt irgendwie eine Eigenschaft haben. Da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du die Leute dann mit, das kann man dann irgendwie durchrechnen, wenn man so viele Parameter zumacht,
relativ gering, dass du daraus irgendwie Menschen wiederfinden kannst. Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass die Daten tatsächlich anonym sind.
Da kann man ja sagen, okay, anonymität, anonym, Forschung an anonymen Daten finde ich total super, habe ich nichts dagegen, bin ich dafür.
So, dann kann ja sein, dass man feststellt, okay, jetzt brauchen wir absurde Daten.
Dann kann man jetzt zum Beispiel dann überlegen, okay, gibt es denn eine Möglichkeit, bei der es die Möglichkeit gibt, dass man,
Also zum Beispiel möchte ich KI-Forschung auf meinen Daten haben, weil dann irgendwelche großen Modelle trainiert werden und irgendwie eine Million Daten zusammengefasst werden und daraus irgendwelche Dinge gefordert werden.
Kann man sagen, möchte ich, ja, nein.
Kann man halt noch tatsächlich auch in verschiedene Dinge gehen, also möchte ich die Daten wirklich in der reinen Form rausgehen oder möchte ich es nur verrauscht rausgeben, das kann man natürlich so unterteilen.
Das Ganze funktioniert natürlich bei Differential Privacy und bei anderen Verfahren halt immer nur so bedingt, weil man dann feststellen wird, okay, man kann jetzt nicht beliebig Dinge miteinander kombinieren.
Man kann nicht irgendwie die Anonymen kombinieren mit den Differential Privacy Nein Dingern und so, sondern man muss dann schon sehr unterteilen, wie viel Daten sind eigentlich von denen, die dann noch zustimmen, über.
Das heißt, es macht keinen Sinn, sich Modelle auszudenken, wo es eine Abstufung gibt?
Naja, doch, würde ich schon sagen. Also ich betrachte diese Methoden, von denen Differential Privacy nur eine ist, tatsächlich als Teil eines Straußes von Methoden. Und du wirst dir überlegen müssen, für welche Anwendungsfälle ist welche Technik die bessere. Du kannst nicht alles mit einer erschlagen.
Aber das sollen sich die Gesetzgeber überlegen, nicht die Patienten.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass man das erklären kann. Jetzt kommt man wieder zu dieser Forderung, die ich vorhin aufgestellt habe, zurück.
Wenn wir Digitalisierung machen und wir die Convenience haben wollen, müssen wir sie trotzdem so machen, dass alle informationelle Selbstbestimmung ausüben kann.
Und wenn ich jetzt anfange, Patientinnen die unterschiedlichen Prinzipien von Pseudonymisierung und die unterschiedlichen Abstufungen und die unterschiedlichen Vor- und Nachteile davon zu erklären, dann wird es schwierig.
Ihr haltet das wirklich für praktisch Quatsch.
Aber das heißt, das Ziel ist sozusagen schon, man muss pro Fall oder pro Kategorie sozusagen im Gesetzgebungsverfahren herausgearbeitet werden, was da die gute Lösung ist. Und für die Patientinnen geht es letztlich nur ums Opt-in.
Naja, Bianca hat das jetzt an technischen Kriterien festgelegt, aber in der Realwelt gibt es ja noch ganz andere Forderungen.
Manche sagen, also ich habe nichts dagegen, wenn das eine universitäre Forschung ist.
Andere sagen, wenn da irgendwelche Tech-Konzerne oder so beteiligt sind, dann will ich es nicht mehr.
Also das ist ja sehr unterschiedlich, wie der Wunsch ist von Patienten.
Manche sagen, oh, wenn das Forschung für gesunde Kinder oder gegen Diabetes ist, dann ja.
Also die haben ja ganz andere Kategorien, die sind eher semantisch und wir haben jetzt so technische Kategorien.
Ich bin jetzt verwirrt, weil ich höre sozusagen...
Ich glaube im 10-Minuten-Takt wechselseitig, die Patienten müssen nur Ja oder Nein sagen und die Patienten brauchen eine reichhaltige Auswahl. What is it?
Also erstmal muss man vielleicht zu diesem EU-Gesetz nochmal, also zu diesem EU-Gesetz wird es auch ein technisches Implementierungswerk geben.
Das heißt, in dem EU-Gesetz wird drinstehen, also jetzt als ganz plattes Beispiel, als Patientin habe ich das Recht, zuzustimmen oder darüber zu entscheiden, ob meine Daten für den europäischen Datenraum, nennen wir ihn jetzt einfach mal, verwendet werden.
Das wäre ein einfaches Opt-in. Das wäre ein einfaches Opt-in. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Regelung zu dem europäischen Datenraum, also zu dieser sekundären Nutzung, die ja dann nochmal anders aussehen kann.
So, und dann, also das wäre sozusagen das einfachste Szenario. Und dann hast du natürlich dieses Ja oder Nein. Was Constanze jetzt aber angesprochen hat, ist natürlich, dass die Gemengelage viel komplexer ist.
Also wenn wir jetzt irgendwie annehmen, dass dieser europäische Datenraum wirklich nur für universitäre Forschung genutzt würde.
Was nicht so sein wird, aber normalerweise. jetzt so wäre, dann wäre es ja auch relativ einfach diese Frage zu beantworten, weil ich,
dann weiß, okay, das wird nur für universitäre Forschung genutzt, ich bin eigentlich grundsätzlich damit einverstanden.
Fein. Aber das ist halt nicht die Gemengelage. Und das wird halt auch ganz schwierig sein, das wird glaube ich in der sekundären Nutzung, da wird Bianca mir sicherlich zustimmen, eine sehr interessante Frage sein, wer wie unter welchen Bedingungen Zugriff auf die Daten bekommt. Aber das ist eine Frage, die nochmal separiert ist.
Die haben wir eigentlich noch gar nicht besprochen. Ich halte nur mal kurz fest, du hast die Sache hier verkompliziert, ja? Nicht wir. Also schau mal, nur mal auf den Hintern.
Ich stelle hier nur einen Auftrag der Hörer, die später entscheiden sollen können, worüber
sie entscheiden sollen können oder nicht.
Und das ist ja auch hier wieder die Frage, der Sekundärmarkt sagt ja, okay, die Verwendung
der Daten ist abhängig davon, wer dann Zugriff hat. Und das ist meine Frage wieder, knüpft ihr eine politische Forderung daran, dass in dem
Gesetz steht, wer darauf Zugriff hat, und habt ihr da eine Präferenz?
Oder ist das was, wo ihr sagt, nee, da müssen die Leute auch sagen können, wem sie ihre
Daten zur Verfügung stellen wollen.
Ne, dann sollten wir das mal konkret machen. Wir machen es mal in der deutschen Situation, wo es ja andererseits im europäischen Raum schon feststeht. Also in Deutschland ist es so, dass es Nutzungsberechtigte geben kann, die einen Antrag stellen müssen, an die Daten zu kommen.
Und dann legen die auch gewisse plausible Daten dar. Und da kann man natürlich auch sofort politische Forderungen reinknüpfen, nämlich wie das Entscheidungsgremium, was über diese ja, nein Nutzungsberechtigten ja oder nein sagt, wie das besetzt ist etwa.
Also wer soll da konkret drin sitzen? Wie viel Unabhängige müssen davon sein? Wie viel dürfen zum industriell-pharmazeutischen Komplex gehören?
Welche sollten vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, Ethiker sein oder sonst irgendwie? Das sind ja viele ethische Fragen.
Also da ist die Lösung, das sollen nicht die einzelnen Personen machen, die davon betroffen sind im Zweifelsfall, sondern da soll es ein Kontrollgremium geben, was unabhängig ist.
Nee, das gibt es ja schon. Aber wie besetzt wäre dann zum Beispiel eine politische Forderung? Also zu sagen, wie soll es besetzt sein? Und wer ist da kategorisch raus?
Aber das muss jetzt auch okay für euch.
Also Sekundärmarkt wird über ein Kontrollgremium entschieden, wo die Besetzung...
Naja, du musst es ja irgendwie praktisch machen. Du hast irgendwie den Datenblock und irgendeiner muss die Daten rankommen.
Dafür musst du einmal den Zugriff geben, aber du musst natürlich auch entscheiden, was...
Also fällt das unter die Regelung, die in meinem Gesetz steht, dieser Antrag zum Beispiel?
Und ist das eine Institution, die in der Liste der Institutionen, die nutzungsberechtigt sind, dabei ist?
A. Aber allein dieses Ding sozusagen, es gibt die Daten für die Sekundärnutzung und da
gibt es ein Kontrollgremium, das als Konzept ist schon okay für euch?
B. Ja, ich denke das ist eine praktische, sinnvolle Lösung. Ich fände das natürlich
nicht sinnvoll, wenn da jetzt nun die Technikkonzerne und die kommerziellen Forschungskräfte sich
die Klinke in die Hand geben. Die können natürlich eine Besetzung ordentlich…
A. Und die Frage ist dann auch wieder, wie die Daten da hingekommen sind und dann darüber
entscheidend entschieden wurden. Also das ist ja dann aber.
Da weiß ich jetzt praktisch in Deutschland ehrlich gesagt nichts drüber. Genau, aber.
Ich hänge ja die ganze Zeit am Kopf an diesem einen grundsätzlichen Problem.
Wer also als als einzelner Mensch sozusagen wie entscheide ich über meine Daten.
Jetzt ich lerne jetzt also es soll für mich als einzelnen Menschen ist es sozusagen von.
Euch aus gesehen eine gute Lösung opt in zu machen und dann über andere Dinge.
Das soll nicht automatisiert per Default entschieden werden, sondern das soll auch entschieden werden, aber nicht von mir, sondern von einem Kontrollgremium.
Könnte man sich ja so vorstellen. Also mal angenommen, du bist eine Person, die ist dann nicht sehr sensibel, du bist vielleicht gesund, hast keine großen Issues und sagst dir im Prinzip habe ich kein Problem damit.
Dann hast du ein einmalige Doctin und brauchst nie wieder dich damit beschäftigen.
Könnte man sich vorstellen, eine Person, die zum Beispiel eine schwierige Gesundheitsgeschichte hat oder sensibler ist an diesem Punkt, trifft halt vielleicht differenziertere Entscheidungen.
Also nicht ein einmalige Doktrin, war das wieder kompliziert?
Achso, nicht einmal, also… Also du kannst halt zum Beispiel sagen, keine Ahnung, die Daten von allen meinen Zahlenarztbesuchenden
finde ich irgendwie nicht so besonders sensibel, die sollen sie immer in die Cloud schieben.
Aber wenn ich beim Frauenarzt war, finde ich es vielleicht nicht so lustig, wenn sie irgendwie
die Ergebnisse meines Abstrichs übermitteln.
Liebe Hörerinnen, bitte schreibt mal in die Kommentare, ob ich verrückt bin, weil ich
Ich höre hier wirklich wechselweise, dass die Leute sagen, Opt-in, einmal und mehr will ich nicht gefragt werden und es braucht eine reichhaltige Auswahl. Ich komme nicht mehr hinterher.
Also ich glaube es gibt zwei Fragen in dieser eben Gesetzgebungsdebatte und auch mit den Abgeordneten ist die ganz grundsätzliche Frage, Opt-in, ja oder nein. Ja.
So, das ist ein großer Diskurs, den wir gerade führen. Also nicht jetzt nur wir, sondern auch wirklich in den Ausschuss und Parlament.
Geführt wird. Und dann, wenn du Opt-in machst, kannst du ja auch immer sagen.
Opt-in für bestimmte Daten, so, weil die werden, also du, also ein total nervig, wäre ein total nerviges Konzept, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Cookie-Bannern, wenn du bei jedem Arztbesuch von deinem Arzt gefragt werden würdest, schau ich dir kurz.
Sie hat Cookie-Banner gesagt, du warst ja die Nemesis.
Tut mir leid. Da könnte man auch nochmal eine Hochphotosuppe senden, Cookie-Banner.
Aber ich versuche, den Stotel in deinem Kopf zu bringen.
Wir haben nur gesagt, wir sind pro Opt-in und wir wollen auch, dass es den Politikern
ins Hirn prügelt, dass das so sein sollte. Und dann ist natürlich wieder die Frage, wie Opt-in?
Und da kann es bei jedem Arztbesuch sein, dass er dich fragt und sagt, und?
Willst du? Willst du? So? Oder du sagst von Anfang an, nö oder jo, immer alles.
Das ist ja aber losgelöst von der technischen Frage, die du vorhin gestellt hast.
Naja gut, die wird technisch komplizierter, wenn du... Die basiert halt darauf.
Das ist ja noch eine technische Umsetzungsoption.
Wie Privacy achieved wird und nicht … Die Frage hinter der Frage war ja, wie kompliziert kann man das opt-in machen?
Ja, beliebig. Beliebig kompliziert. Frag mal die Cookie-Banner. Genau.
Sie hat es schon wieder gesagt. Die Frage war, könnte das opt-in so kompliziert sein wie ein Cookie-Banner?
Ich habe jetzt gelernt … Ich glaube, man kann es nicht pauschal beantworten.
Also du kannst nicht nur sagen Forschung, ja, nein, sondern wir gehen uns mal auf Krankheitsbilder. Menschen, die zum Beispiel Krankheiten haben, die sehr stigmatisierend in der Gesellschaft geprägt sind, die haben wahrscheinlich ein sehr, sehr starkes Interesse, dass sie sagen, okay, meine stigmatisierende Krankheit möchte ich bitte nicht in meinen Forschungsdaten irgendwo hin kommunizieren, weil das ist stigmatisierend. Das ist aber etwas, was man anerkennen muss.
Aber möglicherweise, ich unterbreche dich ungern, aber möglicherweise sind es gerade diese Personen, die sagen, Forschung über diese Krankheit, wenn ich zum Beispiel akzeptabel, also wenn es eine Möglichkeit gäbe zu sagen, hey, aber die Krankheit, die ich habe, da möchte ich, dass auch mit meinen Daten geforscht wird, könnte durchaus sein.
Ja, aber wir können es hier jetzt auch nicht ausmachen, ob das jetzt für Menschen, die davon betroffen sind, gut oder schlecht ist, wenn sie da in die Forschung gehen. Aber wir merken, die haben da ein höheres Schutzbedürfnis, wenn sie Daten irgendwo geben würden. Und deswegen brauchen sie auch da mehr Eingriffsmöglichkeiten.
Es gibt Menschen, die sind gesund, die sagen, okay, macht mit meinen Daten, was ihr wollt, das sind eh ganz normale Daten, ich falle nicht auf, aber Menschen, die jetzt zum Beispiel eine Krankheit haben, Krankheiten, die ein bisschen stigmatisierend in der Gesellschaft geprägt sind, die haben unter Umständen noch mal stärkeres Bedürfnis, ja oder nein zu sagen, bei bestimmten Merkmalen.
Muss ich wieder fragen. Ja oder nein im Sinne von pro Arztbesuch oder ja oder nein im Sinne
von ich will genau vorschreiben, wer daran darf oder wer nicht.
Weil da hatte ich euch gerade so verstanden, es gibt Opt-in und das meinetwegen auch mehrfach und für alles andere gibt es ein Kontrollgremium, was den Zugang zu den Daten macht.
Also man könnte ja zum Beispiel sagen, im Sinne von ja, ich möchte dir die Krebsforschung unterstützen, aber nur die Krebsforschung.
Und zum Beispiel andere Themen im Bereich, wenn es um geschlechtliche Krankheiten geht, nicht.
Weil das ist irgendwie für mich ein heikles Thema.
Das sind ja schon mal Kriterien, die könnte man aufmachen. Das heißt, du hast zwar einen Opt-in zu Krebsforschung, aber nicht zu anderen Krankheiten.
Und dann könnte es, ja. Du müsstest eben auch nicht Leute zwingen, sich für diese Bereiche zu entscheiden.
Du könntest auch sozusagen darüber eine Ebene ziehen. Ja, nein. Und wer möchte, wird mehr auszudifferenzieren, der kann das tun.
Es ist jetzt aber letztlich eine Möglichkeit, ein Raum, der so noch nicht existiert. Wir können uns den vorstellen.
So eine Vorstellung gibt es auch, aber wie es tatsächlich praktisch kommen wird, wissen wir natürlich nicht.
Und wahrscheinlich würde es eher nicht so ganz kompliziert sein, denn letztlich hängt da ja ein Rattenschwanz an technischer Umsetzung dran.
Und auch ein Widerwillen dagegen, weil ja die Forschenden wissen, dass mit jeder Fragestellung in diesem, so zu sagen, Rhesum oder Bauben, den du da aufstellst,
wird die Anzahl von den Leuten, die zustimmen, geringer. Und die wollen natürlich viele Daten haben, denn viele Daten sind halt auch raussagekräftiger in der Regel für die Ver- oder jedenfalls meistens.
Für die Forschungsfragen.
A. Na gut, ich lasse das jetzt einfach mal so stehen und frage nochmal nach der IT-Sicherheit.
Das wurde vorher so angerissen.
Ist das jetzt nur die banale Forderung, das muss schon möglichst sicher sein, wie die
Daten verarbeitet werden oder gibt es da sogar konkrete Baustellen, die man sehen kann?
Naja, also ich glaube...
Aktuell gibt es halt noch, also wir wissen um alle Unfälle, die wir mit Gesundheitsdaten schon hatten, da gibt es genau, aber für das EHDS selber gibt es halt noch gar keine technische Lösung.
Also es ist wirklich, das muss man sich wirklich immer noch mal vor Augen führen. Es wird ein Gesetz geben, das das vorschreibt und es wird zu diesem Gesetz eine technische Spezifikation geben, die dann sagt, wie das ganze Ding implementiert wird.
Und da ist natürlich klar, weil es um hochsensible Daten geht, muss es ein besonderes, hohes IT-Sicherheitsschutzniveau haben.
Die praktische Implementierung wird natürlich ja nicht drinstehen, das bleibt immer ein bisschen vage.
In Deutschland gibt es das aber bereits, das existiert ja, das Forschungsdatenzentrum besteht, die Daten sind bereits da und die müssen natürlich auch ein Konzept dafür haben.
Ist der Tresor da eher so Stahl oder Papier?
Naja, ein Teil des Gerichtsverfahrens war natürlich auch darüber Informationen zu bekommen.
A. Achso, stimmt. Die Frage vorher sozusagen, die Art und Weise wie die Daten da gesichert
werden, ist die transparent? Kann man quasi den Quellcode sehen?
B. Nö, die lassen sich auch nicht allzu gerne in die Karten gucken. Es war schon schwierig
da überhaupt mal rauszukriegen, welche kommerziellen Dienstleister benutzen die und so. Also es
ist jetzt nicht so, dass die begeistert waren, dass ihnen da jemand auf die Finger guckt.
Und wir haben da auch ein relativ hohes Niveau. Das heißt, wir haben sofort gemerkt, da interessiert
sich auch die Bundesregierung dafür, weil sie ja wissen, was daran hängt. Und da interessiert
sich natürlich auch einige aus der Europapolitik dafür, weil eben parallel...
Interessiert es sich an dem Gerichtsverfahren oder interessiert es sich an der Art und Weise?
Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass es so viele Stellungnahmen geben wird und so viele
Sachverständige, die dazu hingezogen werden und Stellen, die dazu was sagen.
Aber wer weiß denn was? Wir hätten nicht gedacht, dass es auf der Ebene des Sozialgerichts so dick kommt.
Aber wer weiß denn was über die IT-Sicherheit?
Wissen das nur die Firmen oder weiß die Bundesregierung auch, was da passiert?
Oder ist die Bundesregierung so, ja, ja, die machen das schon?
Nein, nein, die Bundesregierung ist natürlich beteiligt. Und wenn man sich das anguckt, dann sind ja auch staatliche Stellen involviert.
Zum einen das Robert-Koch-Institut, was als Vertrauensstelle wirkt.
Da ist noch ein Bundesinstitut dabei. Das sind ja sozusagen staatliche Behörden.
Also das Forschungsdatenzentrum ist eine staatliche Institution.
Das beantworte meine Frage nicht so richtig. Okay, was war dann die Frage?
Habe ich wieder was nicht verstanden? Die Frage war, also da liegen irgendwo Daten.
Ja, viele. Genau, da liegen irgendwo viele Daten und die liegen in einer Infrastruktur und die liegen
in irgendeiner Art von Software.
Wer von den ganzen Beteiligten, die du gerade genannt hast, weiß konkret, wie diese Infrastruktur
aussieht und wie die Software aussieht?
Wir haben jetzt ein paar Einblicke in diesem Gerichtsverfahren.
Wussten wir vorher nicht. Aber natürlich mussten sich, also insbesondere das Forschungsdatenzentrum selbst, aber auch sozusagen das zuständige Ministerium auch äußern darin.
Aber letztlich geht es glaube ich nicht unbedingt um so eine Form von praktischen IT-Sicherheitstest.
Du willst natürlich nur so bestimmte Standards erfüllen und du willst nicht unbedingt in die konkrete Implementierung gucken.
Aber es war schon interessant zu wissen, welche Dienstleister und so und offenbar hat der Vertreter des Forschungsdatenzentrums, der da ausgesagt hat, dann auch klar gemacht, die unglaublich krasse Verzögerung, die jetzt stattgefunden hat,
weswegen das Verfahren auch rot, hat damit zu tun, dass ein Dienstleister offenbar nicht die Leistung gebracht hat, die sie erwartet haben, qualitativ.
Also die haben auch Probleme bei der technischen Umsetzung, aber die weißt du natürlich nicht im Detail und es gibt doch keine Vorschrift, dass sie darüber transparent sein müssten.
Sie haben auch so ein bisschen Ansatz Security by Obscurity.
Man kann sagen, normalerweise ist hier im Chaos gerade eine Grundforderung, das muss
muss alles irgendwie einsehbar sein.
A. Natürlich, ich habe da eine gewisse Transparenzanforderung, die ist aber finde ich eher gesetzlich festzuschreiben. Zu sagen, was die da offenlegen müssen.
Ja klar, das fände ich jetzt für den europäischen Bereich natürlich genauso wichtig. Aber die haben vor allen Dingen jetzt Probleme bei der Abgabe der Daten.
Also es gibt noch keine Form, wie sie da irgendwie einen Zugriff schaffen können. Da sind sie also doch technisch dabei.
Das stimmt, ja. Vielleicht verschicken sie dann Faxe, auf denen der Code ausgedruckt ist und dann hat Bianca wieder was zu tun.
Praktisch muss man sich das ungefähr so vorstellen, dass diejenigen, die dann eine Nutzungsberechtigung erhalten, also zum Beispiel ein Forschungsinstitut oder ein Unternehmen in der Gesundheitsberichterstattung oder sowas,
die kriegen dann quasi ein Interface auf bestimmte Arten von Daten. Also die kriegen sozusagen Zugriff remote. So läuft das praktisch.
A. Da freuen sich wahrscheinlich die Menschen von Zerforschung dann nochmal zu gucken. B. Also gut.
A. Ich nehme an gewisse laissez-faire war in der Frage sozusagen, das ist aber schon eine grundlegende Sache auch, dass das irgendwie gut funktioniert.
B. Absolut grundlegend, das ist auch Kern des Verfahrens, aber man muss immer noch sagen, das ist ein Gerichtsverfahren.
Das heißt, letztlich werden da rechtliche Fragen entschieden und die Frage, die hier
vom Berliner, in meinem Fall, vom Berliner Sozialgericht entschieden wird, wird genau.
Die sein, ob sie es vorlegen zum EuGH oder nicht.
Und selbstverständlich streben wir an, auf dieser Ebene zu debattieren, weil das dann
Auswirkungen hat, auch auf dem europäischen Gesundheitsdatenraum.
Denn ich glaube, diese Vorstellung, dass man hintenrum, quasi ohne dass die Leute damit
zu tun haben, die die Datengeber sind, diese Daten sammeln kann und für Forschungszweige freigeben kann, halte ich für falsch.
Ich glaube, dass dieses Widerspruchsrecht in irgendeiner Form darin festgeschrieben werden muss. Und die Dreistigkeit, mit der sich der deutsche
Gesetzgeber da irgendwie auch an den ziemlich deutlichen europarechtlichen Regelungen vorbeimogelt, finde ich schon dreist. Also, ich weiß natürlich nicht, wie das
ausgeht vor Gericht und Horazé und so, ihr wisst ja, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass ein
weil ein Teil davon so rechtlich nicht haltbar ist.
Okay, ich möchte das als gute letzte Worte stehen lassen. Nein, eine Sache muss ich noch mal sagen,
weil ich in diesem Gerichtsverfahren gelernt habe.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das aufgefallen ist, aber die privaten Krankenkassen sind immer raus.
Und die ganze Argumentation von diesen Forschenden, die immer sagen, ey, wir müssen alles haben,
und wenn da auch nur 0,2% verrauscht ist, können wir nicht mehr forschen,
die fällt weg, wenn es an die Privatpatienten geht.
Die sind da draußen, an denen brauchen wir nicht forschen. Damit karikiert sich für mich immer dieser ganze Tohuwa-Bohu, den die machen, um...
Wir brauchen jedes Datum, sonst können wir nicht forschen. Das riecht mich immer so auf.
Entschuldigung. Wir wissen, dass die da eh nicht rankommen, oder?
Fragst du mich jetzt ernsthaft, weil der politische Grund ist, warum die privaten Krankenkassen
daran nicht beteiligt sind?
Nee. Gut. Ich frage dich nach deiner Interpretation, warum die Forschenden das nicht fordern.
Vielleicht fordern sie das in diesem Gerichtsverfahren.
Vielleicht gehen sie auch einfach den Weg des geringsten Widerstandes.
Ja, also wir haben eine gesünderliche Zweiklassensysteme, darüber brauchen wir hier nicht zu reden.
Also wenn ich mich jetzt versuche, mich reinzusetzen in die Rolle des Forschenden, der also fordert
also keine verrauschten Daten und all das Ding, dann wäre natürlich eine meiner Kernforderungen,
dass die privaten Kassen auch gezogen werden. Also schon alleine nur für meine eigene Glaubwürdigkeit.
Aber das scheint nicht. Das und auch, weil dir klar sein muss, dass das Sample an Leuten, also die Menschen, die
in der privaten Krankenkasse sind, auch andere Daten sind.
Die sind im Schnitt gesünder und älter. Also du kannst auch ganz klar sehen, dass es dadurch eine medizinische Verzerrung geht,
dass du diese Millionen Datensätze nicht hast.
Du kannst die ganze Argumentation, die die da immer bringen in den langen Stellungnahmen,
total ad absurdum führen, wenn du sagst, private Krankenkassentaten.
Aber ihr wisst, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht immer das Gesundheitssystem umgrenzen raten.
Das ist eine andere Sendung für eine andere Zeit. Aber anzünden scheint hier immer irgendwann gebracht.
Bianca, letzte Worte?
Oh, letzte Worte, keine Ahnung. Es gibt noch viel zu tun, sagen wir mal so.
Das zählt wohl generell nicht, oder? Warte, ich hab irgendwann aufgehört zu fragen, was der nächste Schritt ist, weil das immer
oft schwierig ist zu sagen.
Es gibt aber welche. Okay, danke, gleich.
Meine Lieblingsfrage ist aber, wann können wir uns wieder hier im Chaos Radio treffen?
Also wann ist es angezeigt, sich hier wieder zusammenzusetzen, weil genug Neues passiert ist?
Wie viele Jahre werden da vergehen? Oh nee, das glaube ich gar nicht mal.
Ich glaube, das wird ganz schön zackig gehen. Aha, nämlich?
Also, erst mal für den europäischen Bereich. Also genau, wenn sie so sind, wie sie sich das vorstellen, haben wir Mitte Juli die Abstimmung von dem Bericht in den Ausschüssen und im September die Abstimmung im Parlament und Anfang des Jahres, also Anfang nächsten Jahres, den Heiligen Trilog.
Und dann treffen wir uns schon wieder?
Naja, dann ist ja eine Entscheidung sozusagen, dann wissen wir wie katastrophal das Gesetz aussieht.
Aber vielleicht wird es auch total toll. Genau, vielleicht wird es auch total gut, aber.
Ich liebe das, ich liebe das, dass du nicht gesagt hast, dann gucken wir mal wie das Gesetz
ist, sondern dann wissen wir welche Abstufung von katastrophal das Gesetz haben wird.
Ich mag diesen Optimismus. Aber letzte Worte?
Erstmal wollte Constanze was zu der Timeline sagen. Nein, wollte ich nicht. Sollte ich was zu den Themen sagen?
Nein, nein, also okay. Dann auch hier, wir haben jetzt eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit der Presse.
Was ist in 2024, das ist meine Lieblingsfrage. Jetzt generell?
Du meinst EU-Wahlen? EU-Wahlen. Es ist immer ein super Thema, um mit seinen Abgeordneten ins Gespräch zu kommen und auch
mal vorsichtig anzumerken, dass man ein bisschen wenig damit einverstanden ist, wie das gerade
mit den Gesundheitsdaten.
Also, warte, stopp, um jede Subtilität zu vermeiden an dieser Stelle.
Du sagst den HörerInnen gerade, wenn EU-Wahlkampf ist, dann geht doch mal zu Eugen.
Nein, nein, nein. Ja, auch. Aber das wäre nur sinnvoll, wenn sich die Mache des Gesetzes so weit an den EU-Wahlkampf ranklatschen würde, dass das ein Hebel ist.
Aber ganz generell kann man ja auch mit seinen Abgeordneten sprechen, wenn kein Wahlkampf ist und sagen, ich entscheide, die Wahl ist nah genug dran.
Es würde schon mein Wahlergebnis oder das Ergebnis meiner Wahl, die ich da treffe, beeinflussen und wir als…
Wie willst du eigentlich abstimmen?
Ja, oder mir ist es voll wichtig, dass ich selber über meine Gesundheitsdaten bestimmen kann.
Aber trotzdem sozusagen als EU-Auskennerin, glaubst du, die geben sich jetzt Mühe mit dem Gesetz, um es noch möglichst vor der Wahl fertig zu machen, oder glaubst du, es wird eher sozusagen, ah, das ist nicht mehr unser Bier, lass mal nach der Wahl machen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine Tendenz der Kommission dazu, kontroverse Gesetzgebungen nahe an EU-Wahlen ranzulegen, weil sie sie dann in der Regel leichter durchbekommen.
Weil ja alle wissen, dass da eine gewisse Deadline ist.
Genau, und dieses Panik-Narrativ von ohne diese Daten sterben Menschen ist natürlich sehr gut geeignet, um damit irgendwie zu polarisieren und.
Wähler in Panik zu versetzen. Und diese Moralpanik, die da entsteht, nutzt die Kommission häufig halt, um bestimmte Gesetze reinzupipen. Also das ist gar nicht so unnormal, dass sie das tun.
Also, liebe Patientinnen, aufgemerkt auf den Jahresanfang. Ich sehe hier im Vorbereitungsdokument, ahja, liebe Chaos-Radio-Hörerinnen, es gibt Vorbereitungsdokumente.
Das wird wohl jeder Hörer ja mittlerweile wissen, oder? Ja, das ist nicht so selbstverständlich. Aber hier steht noch eine Terminankündigung.
Ja, eine Terminankündigung. Genau, ihr habt keine Terminmusik.
Ganz anderes Thema, aber trotzdem ein wichtiges Thema zum Thema, ruft eure Abgeordneten an.
Wo ich sie gerade schon mal am Telefon habe. Genau, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass im Juni, am 14. Juni, die Innenministerkonferenz in Deutschland startet und es ist auch nach wie vor so, dass es keine vollständig fertige Position der deutschen Bundesregierung zur Chatkontrolle gibt.
Hören Sie dazu die Chaos Radio Sendung, die drei Folgen alt ist?
Ja, und deswegen wird es eine Demo zur Innenministerkonferenz geben am 14. Juni, wo wir nochmal den Innenministerinnen der Bundesländer sehr deutlich machen werden, was das Problem ist und was wir dagegen haben und alle Menschen, die in Berlin sind.
Weitere Informationen folgen. Es ist tatsächlich relativ schwer herauszufinden, wo die Konferenz genau stattfinden wird.
I wonder why.
Aber es gibt einen special guest.
Bei der Innenministerkonferenz oder auf der Demo? Auf der Demo auch vielleicht, aber bei der Innenministerkonferenz wird die Person, die dieses Gesetz verzapft hat, nämlich Ilva Johansson, auch da sein.
Weil der nämlich langsam alle ihre Fälle wegschwimmen und sie ein bisschen Angst hat, dass das mit der Chatkontrolle doch nicht so klappt wird.
Deswegen ist es umso wichtiger, deutlich zu machen, dass die Gesellschaft ordentlich was gegen dieses Gesetz hat.
Und wem folgt man wo, um genau rauszufinden, wann diese Demo ist?
Wir packen dann, wir haben doch Shownotes und packen da links hin.
Okay, sehr gut. So machen wir das.
Dann vielen lieben Dank.
Dass sie hier wart und das erklärt, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich kann nicht mich für einen optimistischen Ausdruck bedanken, ich glaube nicht, aber es wäre ja auch cool.
Ich hätte noch irgendwie so Timelines, angenommen dieses Thema wird verabschiedet, dann gibt es genau zwei Jahre, um es zu implementieren.
Nochmal was? Das ist ja Scheinzeigerwitz eigentlich. Okay, also Leute, jetzt müsst ihr ja, da könnte ich euch nicht weg. Erstens, meinst du jetzt Chat-Kontrolle oder Gesundheitsdaten?
Gesundheitsdaten, Ram.
Wieso zwei Jahre? Weil das halt typische EU-Vorgehensweise ist.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich ambitioniert.
In dem Gesetz steht drin, das soll innerhalb von zwei Jahren...
Das Gesetz tritt in Kraft und die Umsetzung muss dann in zwei Jahren in Kraft gehen.
Aber was der Unterschied ist... Und da lacht ihr drüber, weil das ist total illusorisch, oder?
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr ambitioniert. Das ist unglaublich. Also das wäre echt ein Rekord.
Also ich meine, umsetzen, es ist dann so, fertig. Ihr seid tief im Thema drin und könnt darüber lachen, aber alle anderen denken sich, nein dann stellen die halt, dann bieten die halt irgendwie so ein bisschen Cloud, das wird schon ganz gut gehen.
Ich sag da immer irgendwie Gematik und Deutschlandgesundheitswesen und Digitalisierung, dann wissen eigentlich alle, was das irgendwie für ein Dekadenprojekt ist.
Nerds lachen an sich hinein. Ich glaube, was sie sagen wollen, das ist alles sehr viel schwieriger, als man glaubt.
Wir werden es begleiten. Wir werden es begleiten.
Was denn? Was ist ein realistischer Zeitrahmen?
Naja, also wir haben ja schon ein bisschen über den Zoo gesprochen, da ist ja auch einfach
eine Menge in den verschiedenen, unterschiedlichen Ländern an Voraussetzungen unterschiedlich.
Und wir haben einen hohen Anspruch an die IT-Sicherheit.
Und du hast aber gleichzeitig die ganzen Fragen der Stelle stehen, du willst es ja auch bedienbar
halten und so weiter.
Aber was ist deine Jahreszahl? Fünf. Mindestens. Okay.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir vorher eine neue Chaos-Reite-Sendung hinkriegen.
Die nächste Folge Dicke Bretter, weil zwei Nudeln hier sind.
Wir nehmen die schon über morgen auf, wir kommen aber mit der Produktion dann erst. Und zum Thema?
Wir werden, naja, hat ja Khaleesi jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesagt, wir reden auf jeden Fall davon.
Das war auch eine goldene Brücke dafür. Wie entstehen eigentlich diese Richtlinien und Verordnungen in Europa?
Am Beispiel der?
Chatkontrolle. Und vor allen Dingen, deswegen haben wir, das würden wir dann auch erfahren, was ist
eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen einer Richtlinie und einer Verordnung?
Das ist ja noch easy playing, wir machen das, das wird richtig.
Okay, das könnt ihr dann. Das macht doch Spaß. Ich meine, darüber wissen viele wenig, aber das ist sicherlich interessant, das förmt unser Leben.
Wir brauchen mehr EU-Nerds.
Oh, echt? Okay, also wenn ihr wissen wollt, was das bedeutet und warum, dann einfach die nächste Folge hören.
Also so wie uns, nicht so wie die.
Bleiben sie in diesem Feed, bleiben sie uns gewogen, empfehlen sie uns weiter.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht mehr diskutieren, ob das jetzt die richtige Wahl ist.
Ich sag gleich noch was, aber vorher hat Khaleesi noch einen Musikwunsch?
Ja, passend zu dem ganzen Thema hier, Bianca, kannst du vielleicht raten, wünsche ich mir
natürlich Data Breach von Systemabsturz.
Sehr gut, dann viel Spaß dabei. Systemabsturz ist immer gut.
Ich kann nur eine Sache sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Music.